items on economy
so she won't be here no okay but I've
got her written comments
Alex Platts
Miss Kirsten
Chris Broadhead
Ken warns
I've got his written comments also
and um that's that's all I've got on the
list is there anyone else today
it was your name sir
Mel Hardy okay
okay
okay no problem at all
okay anyone else at all
getting a bit of feedback but I don't
know if that could be um
okay
all right moving on then say
notification letters and I've seen
copies of the council's letters of
notification regarding the lodging of
the appeal and the date time of any of
this inquiry
um
I've also seen copies of representations
made in response to the appeal the
appeal notification and the original
planning application consultation and I
will take these into account in reaching
my decision
also receive proofs of evidence from
both the appellant and
um the indicative master plan
and then three access plans is that
correct
agreed matters in the statement of
Common Ground Three access plans is that
correct
yeah
agreed matters in the statement of
common
the statement of Common Ground refers to
a site location plan and existing site
plan
as being the two for approval
um and then there are plans that show
but only for the purposes of the
location of the accesses and that's the
location rather than the detailed design
this is on page three of them
changing land within the green belt
and then were there any harm by reason
of inappropriate nest if that is found
and any other harms would be clearly
outweighed by other considerations so as
to amount to the very special
circumstances required to justify The
Proposal
all other matters
um
will be covered in the overall planning
balance
so that um concludes my opening remarks
so unless anyone's got anything further
to say
um
can we start with openings please
yes Mom
um
have a paper copy and I think you wanted
to emailed to the office so we'll
arrange for that now
um actually
has it come through
actually
Mr Moore colleague here is going to hand
the paper copy up and also the
appearance list just that you've got
them for future reference
distinctly viewing the council's
decision notice the council has changed
its position in relation to its reason
33 years or on the 22nd can we remember
the council's primarily committed and
considered reporting this directional
planning and follow-on legal advice that
they've been received in that time
the ocean was agreed account
minimized costs to the council
and this idea of emotionally community
in order to fill the meeting on the 13th
of December where the council resolved
it will not defend
all the reasons not reason for keys or
two which remains subsequently the
council has influenced on the 14th of
December but well certainly said it
would not contest there was a civil
Suites or street views on
the remaining reasons refusal number two
relates to the council's view that no
details of Dementia or standard Works
necessary to perform an attenulation
basis have been submitted and therefore
in other words because of that lack of
intonation without information the
country the application would not
preserve Greenwell's open messenger
conflicts with the illness hasn't been
about
without prejudice and notwithstanding
the documentation submitted with the
planning application that was sufficient
for both policy office of employment
officers the apparent constantly would
assist mass as verbal information which
would provide them therefore as it
reading the case management conference
the police additional illustrial
material on the third of February solely
in relation to the attenuation-based
scenario of the size the submission
included on attenuation area that is
sort of landscape asked long sections
cross-sections breathing visuals updated
videos for the master plan and
illustrative drainage strategy
environment these drawings are all
Illustrated but were submitted to assist
you Mom and the councilman better
understanding the application
area
it proceeds on the basis that without
further information the proposals should
be assumed into the country to given
that policy
it is an agreement this is understanding
of Common Ground the law requires
reasons to be clear and precise and fall
the fellowship is submitted proportional
to the final application
the opposed positions everyone was as
the material decisions
refers into the core documents and one
case is an inspector's decision the
other case Hunters known in York there's
a secondary State's decision you know
with very similar circumstances with
certain spaces
are
not improve through development so this
judgment is all of a sudden coming along
with those little ill decisions
Mr Robinson's evidence is always to
refuse or two and concludes the council
taken an inappropriate
simulation notices
Mr Lawrence applies development timing
policy from both national and local
perspective and the approach of
determination of the application is
evidence says and policy officers
approach to the proposed attenuation
basis in the green belt drawing upon the
context of the office has been called
and he demonstrates that the attendance
were quite rightly largely regarded as
inoculated development by those
practices
um
paragraphs 150 events yes
engineering operations I'm not in a
quick developers in agreement about
providers versus Brazil to agreement
report this is a lot of conflicts
along at this point it's important some
of the key points to have been the
terminologies in law
firstly if development is not
inappropriate it is
see believe it darling in the course of
the people
secondly once judged appropriate in
accordance with any of their
expectations that out in Paradise uh
what is 490 150 of the apps there is no
second test of giving substantial weight
to any harm to the group of girls that
relates to cases where inappropriate
developments is being justified by
they're all very special surgical
services
and you will again see the reference to
the value and the core document
reference that is the cause of appeals
position it is not a two-minute process
thirdly the concept of openness is the
counterpart in almost four not
necessarily about visual qualities and
does not inquire freedom from any form
of development indeed some very
significant forms of development such as
mineral extraction media programs and
compatible with openness that's the
Samuel Smithson Brewery case and the
Supreme Court but I paused for a moment
now before the seven rounds because that
was the case just to understand that
thanks
it was literally
aquarium station six hectares and two
million tons of rock it's been uh
said the court sorry said the Supreme
Court where the planning officer has set
open muscles preserved was quite an
exactly
I go on further for example families who
consider development for hiding carbon
exploration got involved in compounds so
it's drilling really 35 liters in height
stranded buildings floods and equipment
that's the mineral extraction was
unlawful as it could if properly become
similar to Mineral extraction on your
foreign
mineral extraction
the cause sounds that in that case he
should have done and if he hadn't done
then it would have engaged the
forerunners paragraph one safety
and if that had been engaged then there
was the real prospect that being
affected with the determined with that
scheme with all of those items and
developments would preserve openness so
across the decision of United States
resignation of openness cannot mean that
a proposal has to leave the green belt
on change
it can only sensibly mean that the
effects are openness has not been
harmful preserve meaning kept safe from
harm rather than maintain state of
things in other words there is a
threshold of change acceptable before
harm occurs provided you are one of the
items in the exceptions of the 149 or
150 here of course we didn't have enough
policies
and with accessible reference to the
Samuel's Brewery decision in the court
the judgments about openness is related
to the effects on the openness of the
green balance itself the right decisions
such
so there's a wider contextual point and
that is my reference to Laurel garages
and then for example again even treating
a pumping station equipment cabin metal
facing along with substance as both
engineering operations and preserving
Greenbelt agents as planning offices on
the council deal in the case of Oxford
where the cabin was just I was having a
minimum price of 1.2 liters was a Worth
to legitimate approach when they
concluded that it preserved openness
development of the green bell to range
of forms of development that are capable
of being very substantial in nature
mineral extraction is almost always on a
large scale as it was in the sunscreen
case local transport infrastructure is
similar and silver cleaning pictures
cemeteries and potentially even
buildings within the community right to
build they will invariably cause a
change and be set to openness
the judgment is about whether that
change under sense is too great to be
said to not preserve the green dots and
it will be wholly inconsistent with
policy of law to approach questions
though any reduction will be involve
statefulness
this is envisages an electrical policy
that there will be a degree of change to
the green box will accommodate several
identified forms of development over
social change that's not underlying the
conclusion that openness is preserved it
wouldn't again the whole purpose of
paragraph 150 it's currently there must
be neutral or no change to agree with
that
Mr Robinson's end of his foreign
structure as well as importantly in this
subscribe sustainable organic
further Mrs Robinson demonstrates now
that the proposed development has been
based upon the appropriate location of
the extension continuation basis Mr
wilshaw County Services design statement
the drainage considerations have been
fully taken into account on shaping the
master plan
is sometimes form and therefore the
incoming just happy to accept a suitably
wording conditional conditions in
relation to the attenuation basis in
order to control subsequent Museum
masses and conditioning discharge skills
Mr rollerson sets everything was
examples of access which the apparent is
happy to deal with on condition
this includes matters related to the
appearance landscape and layout scale of
the attenuationary
whether otherwise unacceptable
development could be made out of sex or
through the use of conditions counselors
on the agency to customer in the
refusalem on a matter capable of being
dealt with by conditions is an example
given in the NPD Geo and a reasonable
Behavior arising the cost register
well then turn briefly to the withdrawn
reasons for his he was on it's agreed in
the state of underground with Bill's
cleaners in accordance to the local time
policies that were referenced within the
witnessing one reason especially results
this is further supported by the
opponents professional evidence which
has been submitted in relation to each
topic agree
this being complies with policy lc1 the
council agreed that policy lc-1 is not
restrict or control the number of
dwellings to be brought forward in any
proposed development on the part of the
sign that is allocated and does not
place a capital interest
the cameras for previously come students
team to be part of H policy stc-12
but
this is not a policy related to
sustainable travel
and the basically the information
submitted guidelines stage and subject
has been a possession of time and
condition of the plans for agree with a
scheme could be brought forward at
reserved access that would be in
accordance with this policy
both of the council agree on the
statement of Common Ground subjects
undertaking Highway works as may be
required by timing conditions or
obligations a level of traffic results
in community proposals would be
sustainable and that the cumulus of
impact on the road Network would not be
severe
the statement of Common Ground also
confirms the council's agreements in
relation to stc-14
the events really in positions the
council agree with only for the land
investigation remediation and litigation
works now required in relation to
propose development can be covered by a
talent on the ship with Mr free all
statements where business online and
deliver CSS of that sort includes
consistent with the views of the council
and the co-authority the proposals
according to development statutory and
regulatory requirements relating to
ground stability
and contamination West
in relationships on doctors in schools
there is a substantial evidence that
there is no need for concern subject in
the case of doctors to a payment in
accordance with the formula and those
fiber loads of time and sector and
contained within the infrastructures to
do delivery plan this position is
accepted by the council the local
education Authority the NHS ICB and the
doctors and themselves the normal human
objective
so the council agreed on the basis of
the elements revised last apart would be
possible for a revised sorry for a
reserved matters proposal to
satisfacturing address the alignment of
the public rights away and therefore
being in accordance with policy on the
end
just tonight at that point here is sort
of Master Powers chainmail realize
that run across the summary
this is demonstrated Mr Walsh towards
others
the appeal proposal comment in which the
existing public promise of one
though not including the original
reasons seven seven reasons rather
issues related to air quality equality
third passes in addition to the
supporting documentation professional
statements the impeller relies on the
content of the statement of common
ground in this respect
the state of Common Ground demonstrates
agreement between the past is that there
are no issues related to air policy that
will result in the deal running around
further that demonstrates that the
party's degree and ecology any ecology
issue can be addressed for the
immunization of public Ambitions found
or organizations the council confirm
their agreement that when setting aside
the fact the drainage elements are to be
constructed from the green Wells details
or flood risk of drainage are
satisfactory addressed subject to the
position of primary conditions and
therefore the proposed development also
comprise the policy sdc-11
when considered with the appearance
professional statements on these nurses
such matters do not provide a basis to
refuse the opinion
Mr Robinson's evidence concludes that
the proposals according to the national
and local policy should be approved
without delay in the line of a power
natal elements from work
he also looks at and balances any harms
and the benefits of Discovery in
undertaking that exercise he reaches the
clear conclusion the ability
foreign
[Music]
thank you
uh will be clear from the evidence of
councilor Foster
um so far as the respondent authorities
concern the issue is green belt and
Greenbelt alone
and in assessing that issue matter it is
important that you are do you have a
copy I I don't mind
evening
it could have been
but I will I mean I will have to talk
about uh
um
in in the context of the green belt
balancing in question
which is the boundary running to the
South
of the allocation site in the
development plan
it's significant to know the process at
the development of an inquiry said
uh by which that boundary came to be
determined
when the allocation site was almost a
bit was taken out of the green belt
which historically it had been
the planning Authority had undertaken
and paid substantial review
of the green belt and a number of sites
that were port forward as sites were
potentially land could be taken out of
the green belt
at this allocation site ultimately was
selected for removable of the green belt
and that identification process
you can see Madam in the core document
4.1.12
now even out of the development and
inquiry stage
the appallance were presenting
an illustrated master plan
which Incorporated the entire
development
by which I mean the housing the
landscaping and the sustainable Urban
drainage system
uh within the intended allocation
there was no suggestion then of
encroachment into the green belt
but that then master plan had a new
Havoc at core document
4.1.1 C
the new Green Belt boundary
was carefully considered by the
inspector
and the conclusion which we read
about it appears a core document
4.1.2 and that is her report on those
variations to the emerging plan
where at paragraph 182
she said this
the reinforcement of the Southern hetero
boundary and careful Green Space
planning would assist in mitigating the
visual impact of development and will
provide a third demarcation between the
built-up area
and the countryside Beyond
and will create a strong and defensible
Greenbelt boundary
adequate visual separation
would be maintained to the nearby
settlement of State bill
the prevent settlements coalescence
um I paused there Madam
to say this
at the nearby sacrament of extinct Hill
lies south of the allocation site and
therefore also on the agreed about part
of the amount of proposed side
on the far side or the ballot
it is a distinctive supplement with a
substantial Church installed amongst
other things
and there is clear that visual
relationship between the allocation site
and it
they are intervisible they are an
important part of the landscape they
were taking into account and recognized
herself by the inspector
what the inspectors said at paragraph
182 of her report was true then
and it remains true now
so that is the background by which the
new defensible hedge line boundary was
adopting as part of the green belt
very quickly afterwards
the apparents brought forward seeing
new proposal
which was replaced is the books
sustainable Urban drainage system in
part
on a strip of Greenbelt Land through the
South
of the allocation so
itself
the local planning Authority's position
is
by reference to
policy ss10 of the developmental plan
and everything is
policies concerned at National level
and pretty simply this
that it has to be determined whether
Aussies are now proposed in the green
belt is inappropriate development
having regard to the development and
policy and National policy as expressed
in the framework
the respondent's position is that it is
indeed inappropriate development
secondly the degree of harm to the green
belt which would result from allowing
this development
and thirdly
whether any harm by reason of
inappropriateness
is outweighed by other considerations so
as to amount to very special
circumstances
in relation to that three-fold test
the respondent stresses
as is obvious
that this is an outline application
the bands that have been put forward
are indicative plans only we do not know
what form the ultimate sustainable Urban
drainage system will attack
it is said and to the next sense we
acknowledge that this is true
that there's some adverse impacts of
some
four resources available around it's the
urban Drainage Systems coffee meeting
dated by Commission
but that in our submission is not enough
when one is dealing with a recently
tested
defensible immune Greenwell boundary
this on any view is a change of use
and material for each of these
significantly the indicative Planet
Redevelopment planning quite extent
which incorporated as I have set the
sustainable Urban drainage system within
the damage proposed annotation Summit
are also
used it as informal public openings
folks
when they think about area past seating
and so forth
that position has now been subjected
about fast by the parent
who is evidence before this inquiry
but is that the salt area
that will be an area with no Public
Access
engineered or generated design to
discourage Public Access both the
committee of the family
display things forward
so what is proposing
is a use
for drainage
which in comparison with what you'll see
now
Agriculture and being formal grazing
must be a material change point of use
there is no dispute between the prices
of what is proposed is also an
engineering operation
and therefore both policy assets 10 and
framework are engaging
in saying that engineering operations
are nothing appropriate in the green
belt providers that they preserve its
own business and do not conflict with
the purposes of including them within it
foreign
obviously engineered purposes change
where none exists at the moment
that will
have two consequences the first is the
entire destruction
of the defensible hedler that was
recognized by the development plan
inspector in her report as a defensible
Greenbelt boundary
and its substitution
by a network or engineers
I'm sorry which will be clear from the
public forecast Network within and to
the Central site
that we submit necessarily affects the
openness of the green belt adversely
and negative
the green Bells also of course
paragraph 138 of the framework
exists to serve purposes two of which
are relevant here
one is the check-in of unrestricted
Urban sprawled the other is safeguarding
the countryside from encroachment
what is proposed here
is inconsistent with the attainment of
either the both of those purposes
the
the training system
is an inherent inevitable part
of a development of almost 400 houses
more than three hundred thousands on any
View
it is an urban future without which the
urban
housing proposed could not be achieved
it thus moves Urban functions into
Greenville land and thereby brings about
Urban sport
it necessarily also
represents an encroachment into the
green belt
and fails thereby to protect or to
promote is open punch yourself this will
not be time for some thus will be a
defendable area in which the public is
not welcome without Countryside
landscape features and sharing what
he'll support the estimate
handmade structure
we recognize that there is an
inconsistency
between policy ss10
and the latest version of the framework
they're not the person that was current
when the parent was adopted
in relation to the status of material
change in use
material training of use is not in
policy ss10
regarded as one or three developments
that may be appropriate in Greenbelt
so
in terms of obviously ss10
the change of use is not even
potentially appropriate
and we submit that properly constraint
that is a closed list
in relation to the framework which of
course is a material consideration that
would not super otherwise it will be
absurd if
nevertheless
it has to be recognized but here
that we propose to go with news involves
undesirable things
which I have already dealt and therefore
whilst in the material chain resources
potentially
is
so even if you include
the framework must
say precedence over on a CSS
nevertheless the development still
failed definitely reached the French
will be not in the Premier League
and therefore we have to look at the
degree of arm
and which is training as we all know
to say that inappropriate development in
different belt is by definition harmful
and that is harm which carries
substantial weight
framework policies 147 and 148
in this I emphasize
is a reasonably tested and proven
adopted Greenbelt boundary and four good
reasons
even mitigated through indigenous
the
effects on openness
is unavoidable
And I stress that we do not have any
work done with those who at this stage
because of course this is an outline
the
opponents pray in hand
benefits which will flow from the
department and we recognize it of course
but there are some not least
the supply of housing
so this is not one of those cases
where a local planning Authority is
struggling to read this housing
requirement
at the moment this Authority has 6.94
years of housing management Supply
and we deliver it our dwellings
across the development plan period is
over Target
yes the development would bring about
some quotation of affordable homes
and yes of course it would bring in
economic benefits through employment and
generally through the extending power of
those that who would live in this
proposal on the applications of when
those are
but my reference to the adaptation side
of course is significant
because the benefits upon which the
repellent relies
are those benefits which come with any
good housing development of this scale
without
compromising the Green Cloud
and we know that that was this
appellant's original prediction of the
development inquiry said
so the benefits which would arise
and no doubt whatever happens to this
application will arise within the
application side
or inevitable
and they should therefore attract very
limited approaches only
when balanced against the harm to the
Greenville
at which we will compose on you and last
one
bring it back
in those circumstances there's
inappropriate development fails
to bring forward very special
circumstances which will justify the
harm to the Cleveland Family
and in those circumstances
the local planning Authority asked that
this appealth in this mess
I should briefly mention the other six
reasons for refusalem
um I sense in what was said on behalf of
the Appellate
that their minds have been a fear
on the Appellate side of the case
The responderance Authority reporting
this inquiry received an employment and
put it this way to reintroduce some of
the six other grounds of refusal
by the back door
I can assure you that and then I've
installed the repellents that I will not
be doing that
uh
it's normally resistance
no longer seeking to rely on home this
is going to be results
so as far as the responsible results
[Music]
thank you very much
okay um let's move on then
um with some of our interested parties
um my ideas will do we'll run through
the list with the order that I set out
this morning
um
given to it around about no more than 10
minutes stop asking please
that's again not going to be a problem
and so we're going to play them in order
but what I will do is
[Music]
um
just let me know
that if we could start them with um
Steve cloth please
thank you
[Music]
okay
there are many significant issues that
cause we real concern service chair of
the parish council a mistakes of
disability
the independence sustainability
appraisal of any DDC local plan
published by lupus Consulting in
February 2018 plus this particular side
in the Amber category committing
commenting that it would in denganja a
significant increase in greenhouse gas
emissions
would be inefficient land use
was outside the limits for GP services
and hospitals and I'd just like to know
that
currently the doctor's surgery has a
one-month appointment waiting list and
we are told by the surgery that it is
fully start
was close to and would adversely impact
the setting upgrade to list the
buildings but also the airline Fringe
and intrude into Countryside
what district would disturb local
Wildlife science
would potentially damage ancient
hedgerows trees and biodiversity
and was a mining high-risk area
all these issues highlighted within the
sustainability appraisal have been shown
to be true by the applicants all next to
the reports when law was known about
this science as it is as it is now
so aspects were given a green racing
some aspects that were given a green
racing would have been marked as reading
the green belts we've evidence documents
and it was sustainable review
the whole side would have been given a
red racing
telemarket talks about implying terms
has been one of the most sustainable
small towns in the north of the district
this is possible due to the proximity of
South Yorkshire on the doorstep however
killer Marsh itself does not meet all
any aspects of the sustainability with
without leaving the area of Idaho
in the 2021 census kilmarsh had a
population of 9261.
properties are currently identified as
just over four thousand
the current estimate of properties in
the in the process of being built are to
be determined including this application
at 647 properties to the 4000 within 10
years
currently requirement permission and
being built are 50 properties at
Primrose Lane be simply given the
go-ahead by appeal and raised from 30 in
the local planets of 50 properties
workers now started 13 properties being
built on station roads
13 properties currently being built on a
saloon 10 properties currently being
built on Manor Farm on Upper Road which
is for this site
by the lane
[Music]
application would this be another site
increased in numbers two when the
application is submitted
these figures will be a percentage
increase to the population of kilometers
of 20.9
based on a conservative average of three
residents per household obviously this
would be much higher with Advanced
residential property
these figures would also be a percentage
increase to properties of 16.2 percent
so the residents of killer Marsh we are
just a village however a small town by
the current population numbers and this
kind of increase is not sustainable it
will just leave the village with high
levels of instability in many areas to
be really favorables I would also like
to place kill Marsh into the original
context it is it is located Northeast
Northeast Derbyshire
it is important in the planning context
because kilometers is uniquely not the
establisher as it causes uncle
suspensers
um pronounce it sorry with those
circular City
Chesterfield Borough Falls over this
street and he's very close to the Border
we've got it low
so traffic two are from these areas will
inevitably pass through kilimash this
has never been considered in any of the
evidence evidence documents I have seen
there are more than 5 000 new homes
being built are in the process of being
built or with planning permission
within a few miles of kilometers 3 000
of them are within three miles of
kilimash
Glen Garden Village 2 000 Sheffield 61
000 plus a halfway water third and with
more developments at Massimo
because the settlement hierarchy study
and background evidence documents mass
and much filaments has the poorest Town
infrastructure the smallest great amount
of great States and the smallest amount
of Green Dot protection in the northern
towns the worst public transport service
by far the poorest Road Network the
second worst air quality um worst
employment enhancement possible yet it
has the largest sounding allocation by
far
another issue is a newly openly full of
Islamic theme park was which was opened
less than a mile from kilometers per
pound rate
when fully opened this will have three
hotels car parking and car parking for 1
600 vehicles on site
this application is responsible for the
removal of more than 42 acres of land
from the killer most protected
Greenville
and yet the apartment composers building
attenuation funds outside the settlement
development limits on the small answer
Greenbelt Land that's still remains in
Illinois
it may be that principle playing officer
Miss Chapman has stated in a report
dated 20th of the first 22 does not
believe that the attenuation bonds are
inappropriate development but I and many
killer my citizens believe that this is
when they already have 42 Acres
potentially available in which to build
them without encouraging programs of the
green balance
it's important for the first 22
originally objected to the application
because the applicant had not
demonstrated the application site is
circumstable in accordance with
paragraphs one in three to one and four
of the nppa
This was later amended to accessible
with conditions by the call Authority
but they are all able to comment on
recorded nine workings there is a
plethora of evidence above recorded my
work in some of this significant part of
the hillside all of which will require
significant treatments and we and can
still provide migration Pathways for the
main gases known to be on living side
the Darlington police designer crime
officer comments this responsibility 28
with the 1221 negatively on design calls
that increase rather than minimize
opportunities for crime in the
indicative design commenting that it
currently it's totally unacceptable
from the community safety perspective
the rumbles Association in a response
dated
1912-21 states of the site fails to
follow National local government
policies with respect to providing
access to Green spaces for all
and that that's the totally inadequate
design and access statement does not
refer to the important role the
recyclers in in connectivity and The
Wider footpath Network rather Valley
Country Park and performed with an
outside pass
the currency of theology subjective
response due to 15 for the 1221 to the
application due to its non-compliance
with the mppf paragraph 194 and it does
not mean the Heritage information
requirements
although this has been suspended
superseded eventually by the provision
of man missing trenching plan for the
archeology exploration this still might
mean losing archeology features
represent a potentially medieval and
prehistoric activity on this site in a
village formerly known as child Lord
Mares
which became killer Moss it is mentioned
in the Doomsday Book of 10 86.
the application does not even have an
air quality assessment of a size
specific environment impact assessment
in respect of the site despite
fulfilling the criteria requirement for
both
these decisions were taken by officers
working with the developers who have
apparently ignored the evidence
some indexes behaves and the immense
damage that's it will it will be caused
to the environment in this locality and
the needs
residents is noted that the air quality
assessment was the last minute addition
to this doctor to the documents on the
client application March 2023 however
there is still no environmental impact
assessment
2019 within the external environmental
impact assessment document that this is
a significant extension to the
settlement of pure Marsh
there is a landscape impact impacts on
the highways Network and localized
immunity impacts the same document
comments section one e that there are
not considered to be any overriding
concerns as regards contaminants or
pollutants over and above any other
development of this scale proposed
preposter modules environment on behalf
of the appellant describe the
contamination gases caves shows to be
wrong
incorrect statements are being purchased
to the local plan process to indicate
that the appeal site is sustainable it
is but it is as far away from Kilometers
as we possibly can be I.E not need to
services our facilities
it has a plural no it has a poor none of
the public transport service and there
are no retail percentages of Westfield
Fields business park due job cycle to
benefit the local economy the ecology
will be massively damaged and the
current residents will be significantly
disadvantaged
this development has many other
challenges
the developers say if they can remediate
this may be partially true in some
aspects but some of their own experts
states that all issues can remain can be
remedied
other objectives will talk about
specifics
with so many negative issues of relating
to material planning issues I ask that
this appeal be denied
thank you thank you
employed
thank you
expensive the um the discrete Council
will be uh trying to bring things into
the back door we are trying to bring
some issues
yes
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you Mom because killer
Marshall slashed into the tier one town
in the local Planet it has become an
irreversible presumption it's an
independence
will automatically become sustainable
locations this policy has been better
reciprocation
thank you
one of the prerequisites of sustainable
development is having suspicion planning
of the right time in the right places
this particular site located on formal
ring bell band and outside of Sacrament
development language as it was is as far
as it is possible to be outside of the
main immunity and shopping area
explosive to the neighboring Village
and it challenged the assertion that
beside kl1 is a sustainable development
because of its failure to adequately
fulfill any of the free strands of this
sustainable requirement
s in relevant evidence one of the issues
that caused the uh the council not to do
but in the other areas was
um the lack of evidence in certain
mistakes we will try to provide such as
an Institute
the economic growth paragraph 8A of the
mpbf there was the economic objective of
sustainable development stating that
this can be achieved by building a
strong responsive economy by ensuring
that sufficient land at the right type
is available in the right places to
support growth Innovation and improve
productivity and by identifying and
coordinating the provisions of
infrastructure
the LEDs an edvc adopted local plan in
2014-2034 States as paragraph 220 the
district has a low judge density and
there is a need to provide employment
locally in order to provide the
opportunity for people to work close to
where they live
kilimash has four employment sites
protected and retained over the plan
the Norwood industrial estate in West
oakfields Business Park are the old
protective employment areas into Marsh
identified in the plan as having any
expansion potential
the one closest ideal site was thought
Fields business park is the most modern
of all the important areas although some
of the remaining development blocks was
taken last year having been available
for 11 years after a previous planning
application lapsed the society is now
completely full
December 17 decided that this location
had poor access to local services and
was not compatible with surrounding uses
whatever that means
besides of knowledge which has most
development plans those that come out
from the aspinal early employment search
review evidence document 2017 however
feedback from the stakeholders suggests
that the quality of the supply is
generally low and investment is needed
to improve the quality
nothing is recorded in the
infrastructure the infrastructure
section of the plan concerning such
investment or improvements
this subject described has been useful
uh suitable for open air storage and
ability uses
social observed to be distant from most
Services which would encourage our use
the node size has been available for
development for 18 years since the local
plan of 2005 was adopted paragraph 6.29
are bringing current multiple plan also
commenced that a satisfactory access
cannot easily be achieved for the
remainder of the land the development of
the Sun at the site may also Implement
on education and Recreation line
obviously equal employment economic
topic paper of 2017 also mentions its
dated accommodation its distance from
the senator to the marketing to its
location at the 18th assessment and the
restrictions caused by being within a
hazardous consent Zone
it was awarded 13 points on the aspirin
or early scoring system I assured the
red rated store has read been not likely
to be available for 10 to 15 years
so it was a 13 year old monster lowest
on the story sheet and the SAG score in
the Middle East 11 points is described
as not considered to be suitable for
employment use allocated
how can two six sides when coupled with
the lack of employment opportunities in
the home of kilimage and having no
planned infrastructure enhancement
contribute to building a strong
responsive and competitive economy as
required by the mpps
2018-18 and obviously ss1c which wishes
to locate development where there is
access to a broad range of jobs services
and Facilities which are accessible by
foot sideboard or public transport with
reduced loans on the private data
he will hear about sustainable
transportation
the other two specific retained
employment sites in film Marsha are
owned generally dilapidated outdated and
or full
no infrastructure enhancements are
planned this is according
obviously any one of the plan speaks of
supporting improvements compatible with
their local employment of css2 5 says
that new employment should be focused on
protected employment areas
as well as specified sites for Bill
neither of these requirements
this is particularly interesting there's
a plan strategic employment objectives
that cannot take significant employment
opportunity basically the M1 Corridor
Markham The a61 Grove Corridor windrimus
and the Strategic employment size in all
of which are relevant local or
approximate kilimage
there are also areas where
infrastructure these are also the areas
where infrastructure improvements will
be targeted not in kilometers
as you will hear the bus service in the
area of the feel of the appeal side is
poor not good with only one route which
does not stop near to the side providing
an hourly community service
the proposed sustainable transport
policies viable on paper but totally
impractical in the real world
the only viable alternative will be the
use of the private power of a taxi
this is supported by the Northeast
establishing economic profile 2011
report by Costas de audio which states
the paragraph 3.7.3 nevertheless partly
due to the lack of job vacancies in the
district a high number of people come
out of commute out of the district
putting pressure on the local Road
Network
good support comes from the
sustainability appraisal in the
Northeast Derbyshire core strategy
housing options paper May 2012 prepared
by the latest consulting which states in
respectable proposed filamental
development paragraph time 2.54 it is
considered to be likely that the
majority of the residents from the Arab
Community for employment opportunities
in larger settlements such as check
reorder consistency
all available evidence would suggest
that there is little likelihood of any
significant employment opportunity being
created
thereby significantly increasing our
commuting with dementia pollution
these communities will be using the
philomass road Network describing
described in the Strategic transport
issue in the course of 2010
coolings to the Strategic World Network
the general access and we requested
traffic traveling south towards the
emerald Marsh
Junction 30 and the M1 Chesterfield in
the South are minor grows
the state reports also commenced the
national transport policy is now
directly linked to the climate change
agenda this means that the reduction of
CO2 emissions is a key element of
Transport policy
nothing has improved in terms of the
Care Marsh roads during the last 13
years in fact the situation has
materializing
the opponent's assertion that the
creation of
employment opportunities during the
construction phase will support the
local economy and therefore must be
given a substantial weight this is
likable
make your construction companies and
probably previously tried and trusted
teams of system factors wherever they
are working they may delivering jobs so
other lower skilled employment available
but nothing that will improve an
economic and degeneration of kilimage or
improve the district's Stills profiles
as intended by paragraph 6.2
equal to the comments that the receipt
of new homes bonus and panason tax
revenue will provide economic benefits
as equally disingenuous
it will not be of any major benefit to
given us specifically as this is not
really famous to lead to the central
Council part
there is no guarantee of anything that's
accredited to the last never buying
never mind being a lasting benefit in
terms of regeneration again the opponent
suggests that this should be given a
substantial weight since learning will
be allocated to the Strategic targets
already identified and this does not
according with the Regeneration of
talent exploration
as previously stated known and recorded
infrastructure plans at both district
and county level show nothing of any
substance whatsoever plan for kilometers
or its environment
inspector Housman stated that paragraph
three in an Alexa date of the 18th of
February 2019 to the meddc planning
policy manager the availability of local
employment opportunities is important
for the sustainability of the town this
was actually in respect of dronfield but
exactly the same situation applies to
kill a marsh
in Consequence the lack of local
employment opportunities is is the need
to attribute
um because of an unviable sustainable
transport policy who ensure a
significant increase in the use of
private Vehicles funding inadequate
roads and damaging inequality even
further
the social objective paragraph 8 B of
the npdf reverses the need for strong
vibrant Healthy Communities to meet the
Visa present and future Generations by
fostering well-designed beautiful and
safe places with accessible services and
open spaces
and support communities Health social
cultural well-being
the Open Fields of this location provide
a value and local recreational space for
current residents when using the pride
public profiles the Prosper side for its
size nature watching and double working
you will have more clear more of this
from the speaker
the removal of the well-used open space
in Italian which is acknowledged in
sustainable evidence documents to have
insufficient such space for demonstrably
failed to support communities and social
and cultural well-being particularly the
current things
bit of monsters described in the local
planets have been the least green space
available within the four main towns
1.57 hectares per thousand residents
although drum field has insufficient
space green space but more in filament
way across the necington the other two
principal towns have the uh average of
3.48 and 3.3 in respectively
more than double battle Yeah killer
Marsh is to have even more important
well-used Green Space removed for
development thus exacerbating the
current poor situation
is to be provided more than two
kilometers from the side or in the
smaller portion of existing currently
functioning Greenville land federal on
the side
the scientists proved to be extremely a
valuable both historically with the
second one recorded in the Doomsday Book
at 1086 for agricultural purposes and
during the Kobe pandemic in maintaining
the mental health of local people by
enabling them to walk before pass on
site whilst they join the excellent news
in safety
inspector housing in her final Alexa
1937 or 21 in relations inside during
the examination of the local plan stated
that the public rights away customer
site are an important beneficial use of
the green belt policy Island Seven uh
Greenways in public rights and where he
States philosophy row will not be
permitted unless equivalent alternative
provision is made this is not the case
plan for this code development including
the multiplicity of recent management
which will be significantly detrimental
to the exist
the main facilities including
Supermarket Marsh such as they are are
far distant from the science location 72
kilometers
the Strategic transport issue report at
table 4.4.9 states that bronfield
brassmore technical
top 10 North Winfield all have nearby
facilities within a two kilometer
walking threshold there is no mention of
Philomath within this list
one strategic facility is the doctor's
surgery on Shepherd Road
the amount is great for this surgery
with service provision deteriorating
rapidly
recently published figures is reported
by Leon Collins representative children
the killer Marsh practice has
8693 registered patients and 2.8 doctors
giving a ratio of one doctor to
3105 patients the average Derbyshire is
one thousand two hundred and three
thousand
with another thousand patients
approximately added to the list this
will give adopted patient ratio of one
to three thousand four hundred and sixty
two
the study of social media will show how
according to code Services perceive and
additional 1000 patients will not make
things of Medicine
despite the 1 190 656 insecting 106
minutes being sold
while there is no strict doctor to
Patient ratio nationally the Practical
difficulties of this imbalance to be
considered
um the Consulting response from Dr
Richardson the directory clinical
commissioning group states that this
money should be split between four
surgeries four local surgeries the
killer Marsh Medical Practice the
Valley's Medical Practice is taking Zone
with a much smaller housing allocation
than the end of the class surgery at
British or and the Barbara Medical
Practice the religious side renishaw has
no housing benefit
if the section 106 money was split four
ways it would provide each practice with
47 pounds each which is a one-off
payment which could allow a tiny
building extension but would not fund an
additional receptionists never mind the
original thoughts space in the
Philippines surgery is not an issue
snapping levels um
there's another option from the
Derbyshire integrated care abroad with
lower section 106 modeling nasport
and it seems to be talking about the
same places without spoken to each other
well that's a
integrated care board that the barber
practice says that the environment like
this Falls within the area identified as
proposal the district Nolan a which is
on the high priority list for the county
it could be that the Lion's Share of
this money provided would be allocated
to the power of practice but it will be
even less to be honestly
the contribution on behalf of the
appellants support for the solicitors
suggested that the whole level the sorry
all local practices mentioned are all
receiving new patients and it will be
suitable to kilometers to travel to
anyone before
being registered as a patient
I'm getting an appointment as you've
heard from Council Bluff are two
entirely different issues this will also
exacerbate the use of private cars
considerably
the only dental surgery in kilimash is
not being accepting new patients for a
number of years due to capacity issues
whilst there is an apparently space
within the three primary one Secondary
School servings of the marsh the
situation is far more complex than a
mathematical calculation which is what
it is
available places that will attack on the
split which each area of schools yeah
and just to give you a marketing within
about 20 minutes now so at this rate
we're going to be taking 45 hours yes
[Music]
um
the any uh well I've said the LED
infrastructure plan has enhancement
plans for dronfield play across the a61
corridor the M1 Corridor and windows but
nothing in respect
which has allowed the largest housing
allocation there are even planners to
enhance the bus service Mars Lane
co-listed and play boss but not which
has the worst service in the tier one
towns which is very good
the environmental role paragraph HC
event the nptf requires development to
protect an enhance our natural build and
historic environment including making
effective use biodiversity
in terms of Flora and Fauna the
developments of assign kl1 will be an
ecological disaster
to put this site into perspective if we
compare in one respect it's the Hannibal
medieval Park in Derbyshire a recent
survey of birds in the medieval Park
identified 58 different species of the
news in the Park 12 of which were on the
rstb endangered red lists
on their 187 hectare side the West Coast
side has 66 different specific bird with
15 of them on the red list on a 17
hectare site some habitats women and the
inevitably be lost in the direction of
30 bird boxes and 30 bat boxes inside
the busy rolls is arguably inadequate
replacement
habitat loss cannot be litigated
according to access technology
obviously sd4 the plan requires the
protection or enhancements of all sites
of biogeo diversity
together with sites providing habitats
for priority and protective species the
developer's own experts accessibility
admit there will be significant damage
caused in the quality of the side
location this will include habitat loss
disturbance and damage to habitats
pollution from dust spoiler enough
fragmentation and isolation of habitats
and disturbance injury or death Corona
is not something that seem like
enhancement to me
um functioning greenware will be removed
and replaced by a three-line nutrients
and new bushes beside a main
east-western affair on the side
Society is not sustainable development
in terms of either the NPA and PDF or a
number of any ebbc policies which have
outlined in the in the book when you
have inspects so long between them and
so I would suggest the society is
unsustainable in accordance with the
mptf unsuitable and unwanted enthusiased
um but yes we have had quite a bit in
those two um representations so if those
in the overlappable repetition if you
could just consult your notes
um for when we come back obviously a
good point made once is a good point
maybe 10 times it's the same point
um so just say like nine please okay
um let's take a brief break and then
we'll be coming back with Alan Whitaker
and to start so if we come back at 11 45
please thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
quality
I believe there's plenty occupation
contributes and following policies in
Northeast Dallas
[Music]
both the excess skin on policy which
refers to locating design and where
there is access to a broad range of jobs
services and Facilities which are
accessible by the court cycle or public
transport will reduce the lines on the
private car
policy SD C12 current event we're
supposed to be creating well-connected
places that easy to move around and
which good Priority First to pedestrians
and cycle movements and secondly where
possible with the service and access to
public transport
activity
minimizing and mitigating communities
public transport services and
provisional human walking or cycling
routes we were a new route should
provide direct links to a new existing
book perhaps to cycle Network Services
and the optimizing the existing Highway
networks prioritize more in cycling
public transport and other departments
or sustainable crap
uh policy ID for parallel of a which
refers to the development proposals
involved in the provision expansion or
Improvement of social infrastructure
facilities uh well implemented where
they are accessible by public
transportation
so the proposed framework travel plan or
TP have been constructed by wig for the
imperant and reinforced by the balances
of documentation have been put forward
as a sustainable transport fund
the key to making GPS work is the actual
location of the development and its
proximity to local facilities and
services essentially for everyday life
goes on to the stage the site is located
within accessible War conditions so the
number of immunities and Facilities a
wide range of leisure employment and
resources are we released a walk at the
site when using public broadcasts or out
of way
the whole challenge these things
the proposed development will call the
diversion complete removal or male
immersion for five well used public
health
there's similar to the facilities and
services within the local Farm in
Colorado
the largest place in the last place in
compared to the other tier one access
ones
in reality the wide range of leisure
employment and Retail activities
described in the TP is not so very
important or diverse
40.9 of the facilities provide their
abuse products and 25 of fast food
anorex and these services are also
reload on the side
well I do not assume that the site was
located approximately two kilometers to
kilometers from the center of kilimash
due to the Topography of the area I'll
dispute that this is an acceptable War
for the rapid person
this application which has a significant
change in elevation and Associates
grading of the roots to the Village
Center in the development plan
completely unreasonable to say that
people would make our community by four
full cycle as opposed to driving in
their private car
as opposed to the amount of Inspector to
walk to the Village Center full of
public development sites as this main
system in making your accurate
assessment as to whether other people
would make that deal with Bank of cycle
the chocolate Institute of Highways and
transport published planning for walking
from April 2015 which stated that most
people will get their destination was
less than a mile away we're a typical
cafeteria around influencers
this is very supportive by the
Department of Transport running along
the streets in 2007 which states
apparent 4.4.1 on page four to four but
local neighborhoods are typically
characterized by having a ranging
facility within 10 minutes or 300 meters
walking distance of residents or areas
requesting to my access comfortable
unfortunately in relationship is proper
development the aspects of distance time
and comfortability in any world to the
local facilities must have regard to
complicated the local area refer to
previously
without the funnest thing mistakes that
walking to kilometers will increase
activity levels through this area of the
settlement and will provide new and
improved connectivity particularly to
pedestrians in terms will contribute
towards a great sense of safety for
residents
research undertaken by our own design is
Midlands
2035 division
there's the layout of the 20th century
housing which includes many foot paths
and allergies with varying conditions
and use
many are not fully maintained or sort of
multi-social behavior because of absence
of natural surveillance
but perhaps when the proposed
development side would need to join the
existing core network of us as well our
residents to use the Civil Center please
for perhaps a poorly very poor
Illuminating badly maintained and
enclosed
for these reasons I do not want to
marching the Jesus will pass and I
myself will soon when there was a
limited Airline which of course is for
example here in the urine
they clearly do not look for a safe
environmental seats I would also
certainly not be used by anything
interesting
no plans have been suggested or put
forward by the developer to improve the
situation the last statement related to
improved connectivity and rest and
safety is fundamental explored
the final report compiled by inspector
Lewiston in relation to Northeast
artist's local plan since the duties of
society topography and distance from the
services and Facilities on Sheffield
Road which is not in the optimal
location to access local services and
Facilities by walking and cycling
despite I believe this is a growth
understanding I do agree with a good
start interesting
Westport Road our challenge to statement
has been worldly and accurate for the
final reasons
the bus stop on upper thought Road a
virgin reports being the closest
proposed development sale is used by
school buses early and not by public
transport as a limited
the only problem possibly which goes
down Green Lane is the number 74 which
is very irregular 780 Crystal Beach
Shopping Center we're going to elaborate
on our suitable services for example
foreign
[Music]
to the closest urban developments
to our service will take something from
you to one hour to travel as well
Transit little Sheffield or Chesterfield
Village
gives the limited employment
opportunities
it's highly likely that residents will
be required to communicate one of these
areas for work
[Music]
so
the current population
foreign
board
this is supported by an early basis
allegation where I think these are the
Rock and Rebels data The Experience they
can also undertake in 2018
further
[Music]
within the framework Channel
there's an illustration of the crossword
bus Network within life this is
this illustration the only term is a
catalog a bachelor analysis
there are eight bus routes detailed on
Plastics quite a simple search on the
internet using travels without the
orchard.com and plustimes.org have
identified the following
the cluster is one two three one two
eight one two nine one three four and
one three eight are all school buses
sole purpose is to pick up school
children only and take them to equity
school or whale school and then return
them along with the school day because
buses cannot be used by members of the
general public I know it's my children
and their friends useless
go through the T6 doesn't seem to exist
I can't find it anywhere bus route 70 72
also doesn't seem things really exist
unless the repair of the bus service in
Doncaster it doesn't come close
with 74 which um does exist and all the
costumes
which exists is also a public bus
however this bus only goes to Bristol
Beach Shopping Center and not to any of
the major
accessories to any prospective residents
it also only runs along Green Lane and
Westport road so it would not be
practical for anyone from Eastern Market
with both developing site
I would also not describe this laws of
regular as it was going to be two hours
also we're not receivable for the
individual to travel to work even if it
works in Crystal Peaks
as the early service particular Market
on Monday or to Friday is at 10 53 a.m
and the latest return back
which reports to show the location of
bus stops around
the development side
there's no doubt there are indeed bus
stops working on this figure however
this is not displayed in the context of
once if any public bus services Thursday
bus stop for instance the bus stops
highlights
by school buses
please
and as discussed previously in the bus
stops for the number 80 but also low
Basics
and due to the public in the area and
the distance
very hard sell to suggest that these are
accessible to destructive residents
living closest
on the western side of the side
[Music]
will provide a better environment within
the size and it's immediate environment
about empty movements fully mineralized
everything's within a local brand based
documents so 80 of the economic benefit
appearing as a result of charcoal by
Killers residents
so we know benefit to get along
we pay our scores
and we're just wanting to travel by a
private car for the village it's an
exacer days we've already had
congestants and they're not saying
already being a president's work to use
the Supertramp travel the Sheffield it
was still required to travel these
Progressive groups by car as near stock
is motivated from two miles away
the opening Green Lane to enable a wider
Road visibility display has been
proposed well this is good in theory
most of the road will require Wyoming as
the dangers proposed by Road users is
not outside for those without an
entrance side effects but some hundred
meters north of New Orleans for a
significant on street parking along a
blind there and there's the only option
for local residents and a very similar
safe and challenge a person 200 meters
further along at Westport weather
the proposal for sustainable transport
plan is perfect in theory while playing
lip service to National policy but it's
totally incapable with practical
organization without massive investment
in infrastructure changes
[Music]
I'd like to make reference to the
following previous appeal of the scenes
which I'm not going to miss
um
so I'll summarize uh the development
Contra dreams great medical policies and
office Local 5 2014 2034 which related
to sustainable transport and then we
will be in policy S1 power of C policy
Nest DC 12. obviously ib2 pairs one AC
and D plus the ID3 one two
myself
[Music]
I'm not having this space
um I'd like to challenge this appeal in
the strongest possible terms uh in
addition to the other reasons
I'd also like to highlight some of the
dangers of misery
this development and the unavoidable
cracker delivering
um first of all I'd like to say
rejections some of the points made in
section three of the transport statement
Common Ground document between the poem
and the council some of these agreements
being fundamentally untrue and I think
serious questions need to be asked about
why these savings have been agreed by
the council in the first place
prepared from the document submitted the
council have not conducted their own
independent traffic survey or assessment
and simply accepted that which has been
put forward by the dependence expert
whose job is to present a positive speed
on the impact of development or health
with no independent or opposing expert
opinion challenging their submissions on
the development of this scale became
quantums
[Music]
simply do not reflect the reality and
the practicality that represents deal
with them a daily basis whilst I'm sure
the predicted 2 000 plus additional
daily College earnings that the appendix
uh have uh and quoted both Journeys will
um
James's development will be nationally
acceptable level and one of their middle
charts and tables however if these cars
were to be passing down parcel Warehouse
or down their local narrow those then
I'm sure that view of what's acceptable
they will be different
um in the matters of agreement with
Section 3.1
um it it calls out that they've agreed
that it satisfies local crime policies
in relation to transport and highways as
we already mentioned by these one uh
sorry the bus DC 12 id2 and three
id2 plus the id2 states new transport an
introduction infrastructure will be
permitted providing the improvising this
necessity it is necessary so to improve
the existing highway or rail network
this development doesn't either improve
our existing Highway quite the opposite
in fact and neither does improve
connectivity
now it won't be support economic growth
this has already been mentioned
previously
uh three minimized and mitigate any
harmful impact the environment and the
immunity of the local community
concreting over a green
concrete and open the green and Wildlife
diversity alongside ripping out ancient
red rose and trees destroying
established animal habitats and
minimizing like so it is not minimizing
mitigating harmful impact on the
environment again quite the opposite and
at the same time destroying the valued
immunity
um simulating of course the ID3
um these are the states that they've
been agreed point one uh the council
seek to maximize walking cycling again
this development
um
that point
uh two eight the proposals for major
development required will be required to
commit to promote sustainable travel
through the necessary interventions and
sort of appropriate transport statements
and assessments being
site-specific an area-wide travel demand
measures the transport system conducted
by wig and Texas Tech is submissive is
from September 2017 almost six years old
national guidance recommends that
transport assessments include recent
accounts survey within the past three
years this has not been done growing up
TV uh it's just agreements of public
transport again this has not been
um this has not been done
quick finding a saving agreement it says
with respect to Green Lane the proposed
widening uh addresses the issues so
those three names particularly then was
due to the sweeping position at both
ends of the road the residents are their
cars and bands all the way up the road
visibility is restricted at both ends so
cars have to pull out make the Journey
about their own whether anything is
coming often resulting in need to hold
on with vehicles quite often result in
one or more Vehicles reversing
photos of residents that have been
submitted in evidence documents in this
um this is frequent daily occurrence for
residents there's a large number of the
400 objections will ever tested and the
appellates have proposed a widening of
the road but this will not remedy since
it still does not give sufficient width
for larger cars and vehicles passing
each other without crossing the nose of
the junction or for the cars traveling
up and down they still will not have a
clear view of the road due to the
curvature
uh with Westfield business park at the
bottom of the hill
and a number of manufacturing and
Logistics based there and there were a
large law Regional constant up and down
a Green Lane need to kill Marsh and
Beyond immediately the plan also fails
to highlight the fact that the top of
the hill the houses on Green Lane on the
development side still present a narrow
pinch point which nothing can be done
about a residential park for length of
Greenland and those two properties are
built right onto the vanity of the roads
the experts witnessed single visit to
Green Lane his observations and traffic
should be given little Credence compared
for the hundreds of residents who
witness and experience this same kind of
attestated in their objections
uh one of the soy sex tips about uh
proposes to exit on the Pakistan Road
into the sharp end quest of Anna wrote
this stretch of how Rhodes was
considered an alternative exit the new
development of 26 houses on family
Avenue and the activation numbers
um but those proposed plans for the exit
were rejected by the council documented
in their next on safety grounds amongst
others and as this particular stretch of
road was subject to 30 mile hours uh is
it within a few years at the end of the
50 mile an hour and then the speed at
which the vehicles travel along this
section of the fact that cars exit will
be accessing aside from that it will
start due to topography will make this
Junction particularly challenging this
section of road has had no plan changes
since that application so it's
interesting how can you do unacceptable
for development of 26 houses for now
suddenly acceptable one 14 times
approaching the junction with West Salt
raised again due to on-road parking and
lack of visibility
returns a road into single carriageway I
mean you know the single cars can pass
down at one time and again providing
poor visibility right out of Russell
Road
and there was a lot of points
and West thought Road
um again it's not only an immediate Rose
from the site which are not suitable
sections of Westville road headed into
the village present dangerous single
traffic bottle next due to necessary
necessary ensuite parking and blind
bends again postal evidence and video
being submitted
um this busy section will uh this busy
section of road has been Excellence you
basically walk along that section to get
to the post side the dog walking foot to
the pump at the end of the road and cars
were often seen mounting the Pavements
to get past one another when they meet
each other head-on rather than reversing
or being no mention of this has been
made in any of the transport assessments
or surveys
at the High Street section coming from
um road down towards the village again
it only allows a long section of road I
mean allows a single line of traffic due
to one street parking daily cars to be
seen mounts in the Pavements or queuing
to get past one another when they meet
head-on
hundreds of additional cars during Big
Time book of absolute Chaos on this
actually already fracture sexual Road
residents have no option but to park
their cars on this section of Romans
it's Terrace housing and there's no
options
again because it has been submitted
Sheffield Road uh commuting in and out
of the village it's a nightmare at Big
Times Travel survey conducted almost six
years ago as part of the initial Act of
page and created completely inaccurate
picture and their mods with equipment
day traffic volumes and conditions
tailbacks on the road into and out of
the village are awful on most days
during peak times and additional several
hundred cars added to that relying and
testified situation
frequent Road works on the narrow bridge
which actually prevents large Vehicles
passing one another leaving in and out
of a niche brings the entire surrounding
Network to a grinding hold regularly
again perhaps submitted photos and
videos
other writers around access to local
facilities and bus accessibility of
Health
local infrastructure so with all the
solutional traffic to the Village excuse
the main received where are they going
to park existing parking availability of
already capacity there's seven spaces on
the on Bridge Street of the road and
it's already causing buckle and actually
private Sphere for the passing due to
the lack of space so it's quite narrow
at the bottom of the um
the technical so spaces behind Co-op
almost full rate of evidence have been
submitted from the random Tuesday
Morning mid morning all spaces
um the Audi car park at normal times has
filtered capacity and residents are
already using the Leisure Center
part of their vehicles
again constantly full so all these extra
people coming to the Village will not
have any way to park to be able to use
the actual facilities the hairdressers
are going to tell you quite a bit much
um his name is President as well
um
numbers we've got those but
um but again previous other playing this
brexits about held appeal decisions for
infusing planning applications based on
sustainable transport and traffic issues
um the uh I'll read with the two
sections um the introduction of 12 new
dwellings would have substantially to
private car traffic and a number of
Journeys into nearby towns in my view
that was one appeal that was rejected
another appeal it was rejected on the
other hand the framework seeks to make
efficient use of land's optimal the use
of the potential side regardless giving
us the scope to limit future qualities
and the desirability of maintaining the
areas of alien character The Proposal
would harm the character and appearance
of the landscape causing the urbanizing
encroachment into the countries so the
majority of Journeys by Future occupiers
would be undertaken by private car and
of the unacceptable risks in terms of
Highway sector these factors conflicted
with policies within the framework taken
and the whole in fact a great way
area would be the balance of
consideration points to benefit from the
provision of housing against the
community cumulative environmental harms
arising from their development when
considered in the realm the extent of
the environmental Harmon indications
proposal would not be sustainable
development and the adverse impacts so
the impacts the grants information is
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits and assist against policies
framework taken as a whole
so basically uh
6.94 years Supply this excludes this
application so this this site is not
needed it's not immediate requirements
and
uh so kind of
um as was mentioned by the
previous uh speaker this uh this
development cultivines a number of
policies that have been documented and
documented
[Music]
but it's not suitable
quotes I wanted to make better traffic I
do just have like a little
um
can I just say that I think
this application you know if if this
aggregation was for a village where you
have yet you know the rules uh
they're dying Orange Street who had the
facilities there was a lack of
employment all of that you wouldn't you
wouldn't have the injections this is
simply the case as the power still
wanted to really wear housing credit and
our supervisors developer who just wants
to get as much money for their land as
possible without regards to the local
residents and uh
The Wider Community
um
you know it's not a case of people with
Nick Visa in the 2000s being built next
door to this is fundamentally taken out
a huge section of beautiful
um culture sites it's well used and well
liked
um so we you know we would hope you can
see it for that and and we'll reject
this
thanks very much
you can talk soon
we are face material struggles in
climate change
demand for parks and Open Spaces by
quicker increase
there are likely to be a number of stone
showing health and environmental
benefits you know things now to create a
real shading these spaces and Community
program areas
this is the issue about which I would
ask the responsible for serious
consideration of making performance
decision
let me do you use the local development
scheme the convert over six months this
year
supplementary problems documents
external details of the policies and
developer plan
they can be used to provide further
guidance for developmental specific
sides or on particular issues project
design
[Music]
decisions but are not part of
development plan
supplementary forming because human
preparation on the Earthly space states
in the introduction point one control
the overall objective to the
supplementary planning documents is
to contribute to sustainable the
development objectives by providing
facilities so there are some people part
means other than the private part
this will never happen because of the
personality of the terms of development
and the geography of pyramash to other
facility in the village
the other example sustainable
development objectives by protecting
Open Spaces that contribute to the form
in selector of settlements and The Wider
runs through the advancement of
biodiversity and natural resources the
health of communication authority of
love
the purpose
major development which is successful or
disappear will simply do the opposite
destroying by the very nice of the
totally changing developer kilometers
and generally have another negative
things are under quality of life for the
visibility
not only designs and separates urban
areas and promote visual amenities it
also provides habitats for children and
Corona and permanent health and
well-being
the council seats for products along
from some informal respiration
permissions from
philanthropriate development which is
development
foreign
[Music]
on 14th in January
2022 for also with economy and manager
responded to the planning application
which is just on the other side of Green
Lane
who has fundament for concerns about
historical application
all these words and I quote
I have reviewed the proposals and
confirmed that the implementation stage
for skipping the um
development and this area
because
indicate that within the application
private surrounding the area the coral
manual features and Hazards which means
to be considered in relation to the
entertainment
determination of respond reputation
specifically through the version of
language and of course because of the
close proximity to the development these
inquiry is about I strongly believe that
this statement Delights also to the
concerned area of new development
the new development is available
will bring about 1000 plus new residents
so the suggested plan appears that most
of them will be familiaristic children
therefore last year I contemplated the
whole picture of all three schools in
quranash asking how this development
approved would affect their school
because it is
[Music]
development and foreign
but Saint John's School employment that
the school is oversubscribed
currently unable to accommodate and
increase the people members without
capital investment where School classes
the school is currently always
subscribed and the person on a quote and
the current admission criteria related
to the distance from home to school
means that the purple sound would be
further away than the parents about
applications for friend Jones from this
side of therefore in the published
admissions numbers
they are unsuccessful
and they would need to journal to accept
them away school together in a place
when closer becomes then this has been
used they made this point at the fields
sitting in unfairness or struggling
distance approximity difference
a different process for and so on
Australia with the information that also
Immaculate Conception schools Intel is
also oversatisfied the school this
winter is
primary school and St George's primaries
for Church of England school which could
cause a problem for parents
who don't wish their children to be
taught in a very interesting orientated
school this Township country will bring
more problems with practice as they
would need to bring their children
together
[Music]
from a foreign
foreign
[Music]
challenge
foreign
[Music]
and it is not there to be told the
nearest appointment available
[Music]
information
despite the opponents to the government
website guidance privacy knows notice
for IPO social media
1.4 recipients of residence
2022 vote any personal data shared on
social media platforms is made public
and most privacy settings and being used
[Music]
to provide me with the information
regarding conference or comments on
health care and access to see the doctor
and dentists under the treatment of
informational 2000.
vote and I would like you to provide me
number on cases not names or addresses
the reasons of problems or commands and
the number of faces in the year 2010 and
the number of cases
2019-22 and of course to my astonishment
I got response and I thought the two
locations specified were not active in
2010 and do not experience to have a
previous application
[Music]
to this response I wish to say
that perform third quality permissions
on website studies that the 90 percent
that was built in 1991.
in the response was a confirmation that
the commission does hold some reported
information in relation to this matter
but they decided not to disclose it
not discuss them at all if uh
Fairport information whether to disclose
the information for these Services we
would then be expected for all services
which may allow for a random commentary
about the quality of being surviving
this may enabled people to make
assumptions about the service in between
instructions and would also allow for
information to be published to an
inspection which bypasses the usual
processes for going to check in the data
closing my speech based on my knowledge
of issues which I uh which will
representative impact on the whole
kilometers and those things
thank you so much
[Music]
um
thank you
I think I can take this point yeah okay
Stephen Thompson please
establish your local plan
2014-2034 policy SBC two trees were
delivering Pedros point one proposals
for development should provide for the
protection and integration of existing
trees or the hedgerows for their
Wildlife landscape and or immunity value
going to the development that would
result in the unacceptable loss of or
damage to or threatening the continued
well-being of protecting trees
hedgerones Orchards veteran trees or
Woodland including those not protected
but considered worthy of protection will
not be permitted
National policy states that value
Landscapes should be protected and
enhanced the land Southwest without the
Port Road is one of the few places in
kilimarsh a person can stand and look
South and West and have an almost
uninterrupted view of green fields and
natural landscapes
the proposed development will remove
either holy or in part several Pedros
including five which are ecologically
important access ecology stated that
some of the hedgerows are over 140 years
old
the development plan is to remove the
longest ecologically important atro on
the site searching courses width from
east to west and replace it with a tree
line main Access Road through the site
Wildlife does not recognize Railways
boxes badges Hogs birds of gray and
Sunbirds not to mention all sorts of
invertebrates also comes in collisions
with Motor Vehicles the access ecology
report states that these hedgerows are
of high value because of this their
protection is provided by the hetero
regulations 1997 and is warranted if the
structure is more than 30 years old
which all on site were so assessed by AE
who host individual trees may not be
important species in themselves but as a
whole they are these logical importance
to all of the mammal and invertebrates
that consider them home
66 different species of bird have been
identified as using the site by access
ecology and local residents but please
access ecology reports have been are
either protected appear on rspb but as a
conservation concern red or Amber list
or are listed as species of principal
importance sexual cause you are a
natural environment community
in 80's ecological impact assessment may
2018 table 22 page 1881 evaluation of
species considered protection sensitive
to habitat loss segmentation lists 12
species of birds found on over the side
of these Center breeders probable
breeders or possible breeders six are on
the radius our Pharaoh honest Martin
Linux Skylark Swift and starving
this is the latest status as of 2021 the
house Martin and Swift having moved the
red list since access ecology's report
in 2018
residents have spoke in other words
yellowhammer Green Finch and field Fair
while ambulance sightings include white
throws sparrow hawk red ring and reef
bungee
in a report on the latest analysis of
Great Britain's publicly accessible Park
and green space provision the fields in
trust charity stated that there should
be 30 square meters of Green Space
provision per person in Great Britain
another 2.8 million people I'm not
living with internment talk of a green
space and only six percent of Green
Space provision in Great Britain is
legally detected
in the Green Space index of 2022 the
majority of the area of Illinois Parish
have a GSI store have less than the
minimum standing of 30 square meters
this application for nearly 400 pounds
is also being the impact on the green
space available for residents
particularly in the south side of
Philomath
environmental impact assessment but
Islamic states that the hedgerows and
through removal will cause a noticeable
change to existing environmental
conditions across the sides giving that
connected habitat features across the
site where we lost and the functionality
and structure of the retaining headers
will mean that there is no longer a
functional green Network across the side
the developer states that their site
plan would introduce a new Greenway and
buy Pages for programs which will
increase the totality of Pedro's by 69
maybe so that this is purely numerical
as the longest ecologically important
hro will disappear to be replaced by
land Pages many alongside roadways which
will take decades to mature into the
same natural Tangled habitat of the
current system
the accessibility report frequently uses
the terms moderate negative significance
and the minor negative significance so
does that matter
in their own terminology on page 23 the
table 14 within 2018 report moderate
significance means that the proposed
development will cause a noticeable
change to existing environmental
conditions
this includes major effects on a scale
that would affect a moderate abortion of
the area that is considered to be
ecologically important including
designated sites key habitats and local
science for substantive biological
importance I.E local Wildlife sites
but will not affect the overall
Integrity of the area also included
there are minor stereotypes on
protective species even minor negative
negative significance will cause a
change of existing environmental
conditions including major effects on
column wildlife habitats
70 of the science semi-improved
grassland including the Wildfire Meadow
will be removed the fields are described
as being fairly species rich and contain
many species of Wildflower Market
there is constant reference to
mitigation but the ecology report also
notes that mitigation for loss of Pedro
Woodland trees Woodland Andrews is not
possible
ecology impact assessment relation with
being post-79
in the same document on page 80 it
includes the overall loss of area
habitat for breathing birds cannot be
mitigated for the only origin report
March 2022
summarizes that is all the proposals for
retained and enhanced habitats are
implemented the overall biodiversity Net
game for the total on-site percentage
change thus off-site Surplus is just
2.16 percent
of the decade of disturbance and mass
noise and destruction
under the environment act 2021 all
planning permissions government in
England with a few exemptions
will have to deliver at least 10 percent
biodiversity net games
in November 2023
there are two reasons why I Disappeared
should be rejected under this act alone
if found in favor
remedial work on the site will go on
long after November prior to
construction beginning and thus the 10
biodiversity net gauge should be applied
there is no dimension in any documents
about the project being its own from
this new figure our local Authority
should already be working towards taking
necessary steps to ensure that all
planning applications are in line with
the new government policy in order to
protect the remaining green stages in
that District
if this area would be managed as a
proper mixed use Park and measure and
Rewind space the resulting increasing
biodiversity will be far greater in a
shorter time
because the impact assortment section F
page 55 itself stays there in the
unlikely event the horse phrase and seas
the Messiah was not developed there
would likely be a short period where the
grassland led to grow would become
species-rich grasslands with more herbs
species apparent in the sword
particularly in existing areas of
species of Rich semi-improved grassland
so active management would hugely
benefit this area of Green Space the
market is surrounded by fields and
grazing horses this place will be
suitable for more active management so
that all the residents could enjoy it
since the 1930s Britain has lost more
than 95 of its wild grasslands such as
haymido which were rich with butterflies
and insect pollinators so vital to our
ecosystems and crops
25 local Wildlife sites within a two
kilometer radius of the West Oak site
and could be affected by this proposed
development one level Wildlife site is
located on the site and two others
within 150 meters of the site linking to
the park of Watercourse any edc's policy
SDC for biodiversity and geodiversity
states the council will protect and
enhance the district's natural
environment and seek to increase the
quantity and quality of biodiversity and
geodiversity by protecting designated
local science of nature conservation and
geodiversity including local Wildlife
science
because he goes on to stay that it
shouldn't support measures that improve
wildlife habitat and activity and create
new wildlife habitats obviously ib7 free
infrastructure this demand that
development proposals that will result
in the nozzle or isolation existing
green infrastructure will not be
permitted unless it comes and surgery
amount of such infrastructure of an
equivalent or better quality family
provided in the local area
this 1917 hectares where will the
compensatory area be cited within the
parachute in a marsh
obviously id10 open space sports and
recreation facilities
the council will seek to protect and
enhance all existing open space
including Urban Green Space and
Recreation sites development proposals
that would result in the loss of
isolation that these will not be
permitted unless an assessment has been
undertaken to demonstrate the state's
surface to requirements westall is not
service to requirements as stated
previously the Green Space index shows
that we already have less than the
minimum standard 400 new houses will
reduce that GSI story even further
this policy goes on
the loss resulting from the proposed
development should be replaced by
equivalent or better provision in terms
of quantity and quality in a suitable
location again where will this be
whatever the replacement facility
according to the policy it should be
made available prior to their loss we
would developers concentrate on habitat
Improvement prior to starting the
destruction of the current site and
building new houses
id10 also stays the development will not
be committed unless it only affects
allowing that is incapable of performing
a recreational or Source function this
is not the case with West thought as
many people enjoyed screen open space
and so exercise and since the question
is there is a recreation and Sport and
horses graze the land it supports both
the means
in summary the proposals within this
plan will cause significant damage but
will replace that which has been lost
with something smaller and not as good
this is not maintenance and enhancement
as required by the mddf
they would have a significant negative
impact on a public visual immunity and
the construction phase will create many
years of noise disturbance and uh
possible mental health issues for many
of the residents around the site
allowing this development will include
lots of ecological habitat and loss of
trees and ecologically important Pedros
this cannot be effectively remedied by
planting very young age roads beside
houses and roadways as as is the
developers plan
we've caught by an accessibility States
at various points that there is no
mitigation for how it had lost it also
highlights the fact that the overall
loss of the habitat of breeding birds
cannot be mitigated
these issues should be considered
against their assertion that some of the
adverse effects can be mitigated but not
apparently some of the most important
ones for many political perspective
and finally the quote our most respected
and experienced naturalistic
over a cheap places equipment as a whole
is one of the most
they're rich in places in Britain as a
whole is one of the most nature things
countries in the world
of over development on Westport Fields
we're doing nothing to improve that
situation
with it being at the age of a small town
which is neither the infrastructure for
all the facilities to accommodate such
approaching
my everything
um I'd like to take this opportunity to
expressive evidence concerns about the
effectively proposed development on air
quality and the environment
at the current time we're all very aware
that breathing in Jersey
airplanes heart disease and cancer in
fact nearby Sheffield City Council has
introduced the queen Air Zone in the
city center for playing plan members
issues red lines on many ways which have
become further much traffic due to
overpopulation and the N1 earn less than
one mile from the development so I think
the marshes with photovolis is subject
to speed institutions in the interests
of kingdom
unfortunately for the residents of
Panama should the pollution day to the
published Farmers department for
leveling up housing and communities in
2019 evidences that color Marsh is the
second most polluted area in the
Northeast darkship with an air quality
School of 0.93
this is based on closing of four
pollutants nitrogen dioxide Benzene
sulfur dioxide and particulates or which
cause anal health
for this reason then that is reflected
the proposed large cell development on
an already compromised Airport
all enforced by oeddc
in fact the environmental planning
officer of naddc included that there are
insufficient browser requirements
quality assessment or an environmental
impact assessment this is clearly income
correct and in contravention of The
Institute of Bank of international
guidelines which is taken the assessment
potential distance pass should be
required when their human receptors
within 350 meters at the site boundary
the town on Country planning the
environmental impact assessment
regulations 2017 this development is a
schedule to project project and
therefore an EIN must be pared out if
the Sun is likely to have a significant
impact on the environment by virtue of
its nature size orientation and
furthermore policy scc-13 which states
that all development patients will be
assessed in relation to their impact on
air light noise ground and water
pollution plant information will be
refused for anything proposal while
pollution would cause non-exstructural
use to Public Health policy applying or
the environment furthermore it states
that planning out for patients with the
potential to pose of this the pollution
should be accomplished by an assessment
of the likely impact of the development
of Environmental Quality
on 9th and Charles of August 2021's for
Johnson challenges provision about email
but receiving a response
we know that we'll developer has finally
it should existing the report as the
assessment fantastic documented
preparation for this inquiring very
reasonably on the second of March 2023
we're still not seeing the environmental
impact assessment and maintained that
this is the provides who does cc13 and
the eia with organizations mentioned
this is a large scale development of
currently green land in a Seminole
location the sheer size of the
development and potential impacts on
pollution due to the known presence of
contaminants nuisance traffic Road
Network I do things to speak
conservation infrastructure and
production of Weights no respectful
assessment
the obvious reality is that this project
is likely to have a significant effect
on the environment and we do not
understand the basis for energy to
exceed screening divisions within
country
if each doesn't have potential green
patented significant impact on
environmental practices in comparison to
physical use and question what does
the air policy assessment undertaking
acknowledges that this development is
currently and an air quality assessment
is necessary in accordance with the
national or local planning policies
the residents in Marshfield let down by
any duties they needed to ensure that
their quality assessment was undertaking
in a timely manner as they stumbled
through a missed opportunity for your
analysis of the evidence and identify
patient's defects which could
potentially have made some more concern
about the impact on their policy and the
level of mediation required we can
physically delaying the developer
producing such a report and naddgcs
failing to protect the resident's
interests as quick Investments after
disadvantage at this payment
now I'm by no means an experts on their
policy but I have you know the following
observations on the air quality
assessment report submitted by the
developer which passed out on this
conclusions and requires failure
investigation
firstly the conclusions are based on the
premise that the air pollutants in the
area are the most available n2os in fact
it's evidence identity marshes the
second most polluted science in an
office establishment
the report is a desktop report it does
not take into consideration specific
environmental factors of importance of
the site such as the fact that
development is in a windy location and
surrounded by roads on which are narrow
immediately adjacent down to the wrong
lane which will result in iPhone
Vengeance and stationary traffic traffic
is limited but this is not taken into
consideration when predicting the future
of quantum source
data has been taken from two sensitive
reflection you know patients on Green
Lane neither only one pay started as
they are not currently in a populated
area
there are no receptors on Westport Road
which is an obvious solution of access
and an awesome congested due to the
layout of the road as evidence from the
photographs submitted
there is also a lack of data on
Hill Road which is and will increasingly
be a major road route of access to the
M1 we've already seek use of traffic
along this world whenever there's a
problem I mean in mind traffic traffic
is purposely died to divert it this way
and we have photographic evidence to
prove this point and again there is no
impact on count of the impact on VIP
engines on this road when predicting the
future nitrogen dioxide levels within
the report
furthermore it's not clear how many
additional Journeys the predicted
National Day on site concentrations are
based on as a residence of the direct
area we know that there are no reliable
in regular public transport laws and it
is
given the predicted impact is negligible
despite an estimate of over 2 000
additional daily journals respect that
the liberal journalists has been likely
to be under escalated which is not to
account for arguing engines
the report also does not take into a
primary impact other nearby developments
on the already compromise our country
Marsh there is significant level of
development in adjacent areas such as
Cloud which is involved in the district
council and the townships of South
Sheffield
we suggest that it is obvious that they
still have a community significant
effect on inequality yet there is no
account of this civilian report
importantly it is the fact that the land
contains contaminated soil
amongst the contaminants are politically
aromatic hydrocarbons which are
especially dangerous and could cause
cancer
given the level of Alternatives thrown
on the development site and the lack of
real evidence has to be where this
accumulation is will suggest that this
requires specific attention
the report accepts that the sensitivity
of the area to adjust toiling affects on
people and property will be on
the residents are significantly simple
assigned even with mediation of hits
there will be a high risk of breathing
in these dangerous contaminants when you
plant some Wildlife absorbing the sound
the presence of contaminated land is not
reflected in the assessment and it has
been concluded that the recipient is low
construction traffic of 2000 plus
additional car journals per day is
directly adjusted to a very narrow
footpath and houses directly on the road
including grade two listed buildings
I have personal experience of living on
Waverly which is another large hour of
development in the construction phase
and I've seen the just some mass of
creative front restriction on the
removal of products from the Sun despite
the immunition methods the reality is a
daily level they are just on all
external senses roads and cars and also
on internal windowsills due to access to
events adding contaminants the duration
of the works on the post boxing tutor
homes and pedestrians needs location is
more than a nurses and significantly
concerning
furthermore there is no accountability
measures to ensure that they are
provided this is something that the rate
of resonance Waverly are currently
battling within respected deadly on the
island institutional Constitution
traffic
ultimately the residents are concerned
that the air qualities must be just not
take you to account fast that you may
decide simply vulnerable and basis and
assessment on data which does not apply
for women's factors
dangerous contaminants and chocolate
pollution
the simple fact is that this
developmental does not go into Penn
Marsh this involves destruction
destruction of the green area which
promotes clean air and well-being and
even on the developer's own assessment
it will reduce our energy
environment
there is more advantage of patients at
least increasing rates that there are
more suitable development science
foreign
[Music]
policy framework Riders and of the local
plan policies ss11 A1c
by my friends honestly also seven who of
course not to look at a maintain the
functionality and under balanced
character of the local settlement Gap
see do not result in the erosion of
existence and film and separation and
identity created by the individual
character of those spaces
the proposed development would be
clearly seen in the Station Road the
road leading from Smith Hill towards
kilimage
there aren't too much properties
currently visible are those few
properties along the ridge line along
upper Third Road
for 400 houses spawning down the
hillside on one screen Fields would be a
complete intrusion into the countryside
that the settlement map space between
Hillary Marsh and stick Hill
the developers have claimed that they
are only going to build as far as
existing
Business Park I remember the business
park is nestled in low line ground to
the left with the post side completely
unseen from spin him due to the lay of
the land an existing tree short for
cover
the developments on the other hand is
completely visible from the hillside as
it drops four to three meters from the
top of the hill to the mountain this
will be clear to sleep when your site
visits as it isn't necessarily clear on
paper
besides also Bears remarkable
similarities in descriptive terms to its
size at eckington ec1 which was quite
popular in a room from the local plan
a letter from the inspector to Northern
Star which District Council planning
office manager data the 18th of February
existing developments externals along an
elevated Ridgeline creates a distinctive
West East access to the buildup area in
contrast the proposed science allocation
would extend in the north south down the
hillside openly got views of the
developments the new dwellings access
road and changes to the vegetation would
be readily visible due to the Topography
of the sides
this exactly describes the situation at
the Westfield side and how it is viewed
When approaching baseball field as long
as it is around
I would also refer you to a previous
planning inspectors finding on a
proposed development
also building on open Countryside
between two supplements and their
decision to reject that development due
to the emotion of the second
this application was DCS which is
25631 TBC inspector Jennifer guys the
insulin is available if you need it
will fixer in her view found that
proposed Zone would not represent in
filling or rounding off but would appear
as a projection into a Countryside
while accepting that this would only
have a local impact she found that this
would be moderately adversing landscape
terms and highly adverse in visual terms
she concluded that the proposal was all
sustainable regardless of the housing
language Supply position because it was
contrary to the authorities of bonuses
policy
to preserve the settlement Gap
where Scott's fields and shippers are
valued as local immunity the dog walking
Walking Horse grazing and Wildlife and
argued by the local population as an
accessible Countryside between killer
martians think Hill and Northeast Albany
District Council said clearly in their
own local plan what it is essential for
these to be maintained
refers to the process by which new
development is built in the open
Countryside outside of established
settlements and without sufficient
regard for the impact on existing
communities among the local environment
gappy version can result in the
fragmentation of the countryside the
loss of agricultural land and decreased
participating the same all of which can
undermine the sustainability of local
communities this is exactly what will
happen with the post-development is
allowed to go ahead
older due to please the jokes please
um
for the science plan so
the application documents for both
strange being channeled by our coverage
foreign
um I've got selection photos here as
well I think he wants to meet you
uh during some comments I for example of
the roads
um have floating without a major or
something whether they're taking place
in our area
regular food in Japan those and will
continue to go on Spring Hill Road which
is The Code by default and may not
seriously
classified but it'll be used as a wrap
foreign
[Music]
terms
on suit system is man-made engineered
system which is not naturally occurring
in this landscape and will serve as
construction drivers and strange that
does not seem to these water levels but
just diverges course is great
on the Coliseum we are investigate
we do not believe the war against Robert
will make things worse it's the natural
absorption of the development Society
being diverted to a single Channel which
the same endpoint which always
site
the construction will involves
significance alterations
development and select from both
significant remediation between stolen
this is an open the book ground system
The Talk would also presents additional
verses about people in the environment
which is also not clear what risk of the
president of the stories in the history
of learning in this specific area and
what's the impact of residual use this
is
into this long-term stability
whilst developers may also claim that
the assistance can also assist by A
diversity they call it represent
significant risk of diversity outside of
their own boundaries for example
1998 biology
showed that the company was part of
there and was cleaning of remediate and
improve the side and removed the covert
Direction More from the side into our
program this was removed because there
was significant increase in Iron
concentrations between the entrance and
existing povert
[Music]
Wildlife sites now associated with our
work
also your routine of a wildflower Meadow
at this location will all sort of not
expect from soil stability a probability
supported by the world and Technical
Gardens
they advise the conference room
structural workers provide significant
civil stability as well as providing
habitats and feeding stations for our
binary important pollinators
additionally
water the closing to the system will not
just be more rainwater as the land
absorbs in its present State this is
likely to welcome any contaminants
that may exist in the land already or
influence potentially on the general
public and residents use of the roads
and Pathways corporate development
once it's built
the risk for contamination a bit oil
needs cleaning chemicals
non-biodegradable to litter and other
challenging decade's child growing
system and called Ishmael experience is
good additional cause environmental
health problems affect water flow
increased fireworks
already adding to what potentially at
high risk sites so because of this
systemic money situation these typical
situations like our significant impact
on the biodiversity in the green
military
stations worldwide politics
in additional ground Constitution
subsystem make sure it is
residents especially younger age groups
that may or may not be aware of the risk
of change the nature of these facilities
also the state of the world from women
and directors to help them actually the
person through the Constitutions which
are either intentional or
unintentionally
in summary we still maintain now this
side to have developed a full-inclusive
global reciprocities of green line is
still called road which are currently
susceptible to Improvement funding
enclosure although the period between
fully while reducing positive climate
change disability is not to worry with
your event which has now happened at all
times in the past two and a half years
the development will also roughly
through all Sites most of its abilities
to absorb excess water the brain will no
longer fall longitude and be absorbed by
a cause significant rainfall than
because of the two public moving area
still on run onto the road system mainly
between the main carried away
foreign
[Music]
number three for now
thank you
just please
like like Point challenge to the
inspector that there are five existing
podcasts across this side all with
panoramic views of all the countryside
and he was across for the garbage Hills
in the distance
of elected by dog walkers and then we're
Delight
and also remembered association with all
the object of this development taking
place so that many religions
remember
being completely or partially
obliterated
this would require Authority for a
distinguishments or significant
diversion to which you stay at Central
with object as this developer fails to
follow a national and local government
policies with respect to providing
access to green and orchestrations for
all
to change Green Mountain footpaths
retirement curbside paths in the state
and certainly less enjoyable for Public
Health
section
119.6 of the public back diversion order
state that any diversion order was taken
into account what the diversion would
have on the public enjoyment as a whole
and by coming into operation of the
order we have on Overland and served by
existing rights of way
now I'm not sure if the inspector is
aware that three of the existing
properties are looking Road have access
to the public broadcast which is
proposed of the law
now right of access to understand that
if you'll have access to any public
broadcast for more than 20 years that
the Central Park cannot removed without
the express permission of the people
that it makes
I noticed from the plan that the podcast
seems to go halfway through the field
this football
always in like 56 years on planet Earth
has always ruled directly at the back of
the existing properties boundaries to
which as I have stated three properties
upgraded access to the path
one property has an access since 1952
was since 1960 until to my knowledge
just the early images
each properties have actually suspected
by the right of access or via legal
easement by prescription
in order to walk but to maintain their
boundary hedge and in contradiction the
heart of the states
the bottom page is not theirs as this
page is clearly on my Beats
should this development you see
information on the thought that we
attempt of the Norms then this matter
will not cause
are also like to add the harm of the
spirits are shown completely multiple
attempt with existing residents with the
proposed properties being all five to
seven liters from their boundary hedge
with a complete route to loss of privacy
totally
appointed I just wanted to ask the
question what should this development
gain permission
when during construction work that the
natural pole that runs through this side
is planted
and all will be held responsible
thank you
okay I'm sorry Legacy so throughout the
UK there are numerous examples where
planning decisions have been rejected
due to the risk involved in developing
former Congress Acts well the Amber
Valley Rugby Club application within the
lower District so with the districts of
lower silicones Derbyshire has great
similarities and many shared reasons as
to why this application should be
rejected
extensively dating from 1923 to 1984 and
as outlined by Guidance Syria SB 32
introducing superseded by
c7588 abandoned mine workings manual
manual records from numerous areas
across the country vastly different from
actual workings within the congressides
let's not forget the sole intention of
these Courier Service was to remove us
conscious of code from the ground as
quickly as possible during the
significant boom in the use of color the
fuel source
unlike today there was a distinct short
form and working procedures and guidance
for documentation and the main focus was
a quick removal of coal and the shallow
cold scenes as a narrative install
investigation reports
could be more could modernize to be one
of these saris where the record of
diverging the locations the five scenes
of shallow mining are both unreliable
unreliable and they emphasize the vast
areas they've used
from the British coal records five
mining shops are shown with the desires
but the locations of only four of these
can be confirmed by the soil
investigation report was just requires
an assumption of inaccurate recordings
of the working within this series
when discussion with former employees of
the corollary the suggestive starting
the winters with mining chefs and
ventilation chefs for the provider
records on the show fire of sharks noted
and only four of these can be accounted
for
this worrying element of the unknown
along with a very real potential of gas
escaping from the underground tunnels
and is developing extremely
environmentally concerning not to
mention the visible sinkholes that can
be seen across the series
as outlined within the technical
information if or more likely when the
fifth chef and any further chefs are
discovered and these could be plentiful
due to the level of Works carried out
within this site over the 61 productive
years it would then trigger a 20 meter
no working Zone from the discovered
position along with us proposed in
section seven the technical notes a
strong recommendation that all shafts
need to be fully remediated that will be
treated in capital reinforced concrete
further to this a 45 degree Mill build
Zone around each Gap is also recommended
the potential of disturbing the natural
fold line that runs through the middle
of this element is very real which in
turn May then create a natural migration
path for the Mind gases to be released
which would be a serious crisis event
for the developer and more importantly
for the health of the surrounding
residents
in fact across the railroad where the
old colony buildings stood on Westfield
field row there are records of the cold
Authority carrying out remedial Works in
this area due to an issue raise with gas
released this is just 40 meters away
from the goals development
with very little confidence in the
historical information provided by the
coal board these 20 meter now working
zones could be scattered across the size
disrupting if not decimating the layout
of the preparation begging the question
as to whether this is a variable
development or if it is more likely this
site will sit empty nearly filling the
pockets of the developer because they
leverage their increased land value
meanwhile holding the local community
window
a review of similar applications there
are numerous precedents where previous
mining sites have been rejected upon Him
due to a lack of confidence and
historical records
I beg to argue that even a fraction of
any furthery further findings leading to
further remediation of the already
extensively burdened sites will cause
extreme Financial pressures from the
developer
historical Authority having no
objections within their comments they do
reach the table of bust their own
caveats that must be dealt with
and this is just for the information
known about really about the development
it pays no significance to the possible
amounts
both around Remediation in the past 15
years the salary was owned by our
British coal was gifted to the local
children's Football Club Columbus to be
used as a base for their growing number
of junior boys and girls teams
despite the sign of it being signed up
as safe and has been remediated to the
correct levels on the first day that
football was played at the new home of
kilimath dynamos a significant injury
was sustained by a player resulting in
hospital treatment and legal proceedings
and this was due to mining related
objects resurfacing all the pictures
that are being tested when signed up to
allow children to play football
this Saturday higher mode is less than
850 meters from this proposed
development who's giving further
strength to the argument the remediation
of a formerly Collier could still throw
up issues long after the remediation
process is confident and even when it's
deemed acceptable the children's clown
I will review the presented information
and then in my role as a construction
professional I've done this many times
the cost of the remediation of the
ground is of significant concern to the
viability of the construction of this
development
it would cost approximately just over
one million pounds just to turn over the
ground of thought selectors to create a
construction platform with obstructing
removal to two meters and his normal
construction practice
parts of this a further six million
pounds which we've actually costed
and to chapter start remove the
contaminants and cap and fill the
various shafts situated on sides and
materials management plan would need to
be strictly adhesive
do you think we adhere to I would
suggest the watching brief required due
to the level of contaminants known
within the SI report which would be a
responsibility of the Northeast Irish
Council to ensure that they're carried
out correctly I do note from the
conditions on the planet I don't think
that's been addicted
if the development is indeed to the
unviable financially then there will
inevitably come the downgrade of the
planning conditions and we're laying in
the developers commitment especially to
develop those levels of affordable
housing
so it's a closing statement on behalf of
the residents as an opposition we hope
to obviously CLA express our concerns
that there are serious questions over
the viability of this development Grant
from this application which granting a
site for potential and develops today
whilst leveraging the financial position
of the proposed developer with increased
land value
are so often happens within the
construction industry there's a real
risk the developer could use this
leverage in an attempt to develop other
more financially prosperous service
leaving Northeast Derbyshire unable to
fulfill the local plan that they are
attempting to run the killer Marsh was
satisfying
in the current climate for the inflation
arrives in solar roof the building
industry is still going to code with the
price increases which would put even
further stress on this development's
viability
providing a house Builder to develop
this site
when the house building industry slowed
down would be extremely difficult
we the residents of killer Marsh have
actually ready to pass amounts of
information thrown in our Direction in
our own time to defend our community's
position so disappointingly under
balanced by Northeast Irish Council
we have identified factual actresses and
we have exposed numerous areas where
this development application is like
wanting and the numerous ways this will
negatively impact the quality of life of
not only the residents of Westville but
the entirety of killer marching
surrounding areas
so it's agree to a recap
there has been apparent disregard for
sustainable development in all three
discussed areas that's economically
socially and environmentally
but there's a severe absence of
sustainable transports inside
direct transport leads from the lack of
infrastructure surrounding its proposed
development
the lack of fundamental air quality and
environmental impact awareness
the game is outlined on the drainage
strategy
the catastrophic ecological damage
the absolute closure of the supplement
Gap
the potential archaeological harm
is fairly to protect historical and
green foot plants the complete unknown
of Manning Legacy of the old Urban side
and finally the underlying concerns over
the viability of this development as
residents of Illinois
the military co-owned we urge you to
uphold the original and correct decision
and reject this planning application
once again this development is unviable
unsustainable and suitable and unwanted
please
and now Hardy
okay
hi everyone
I'm here to represent the Ramblers
specifically so I was also asked to
present evidence on the art of the
council
predominantly today all I want to talk
about is the book first because there
are more confident people who talk about
the other aspects in this application
there are five bookmarks got in this
site
and I'm going to examine the drawings
it would appear that the development
will result in the book class being
either completely or partially destroyed
as a podcast
thus for the development to continue
with the necessary to raise and obtain
approvals
and extinguishment or significant
diversion
should this occur then there's just fill
the Northeast out of the surrounding
organization have authorized me to put
me in a formal objection
the reasons
the grantinople which is the development
of Landover which theory of the public
or out of waves is not in itself
constitute Authority for interference
with the right of way or for his closure
or division but with separate issues
should the development be considered for
the development wondering would say
Republic right away
um
then in the case in question this the
development could be carried out whilst
maintaining the existing pullback
Network including character and location
in other words it needs to be if it's
still there it needs to be at a book and
not as a certain amount
building overpass and replacing them
with roadside causeways will
considerably lessen the enjoyment of the
areas caused by the park and one of the
two tests for the diversion of the
footpath is that it must be as enjoyable
to the public as it was before it was
diverted
further this is a green belt so it
providing access to Green spaces for a
considerable number of vehicle which has
already been episode many times and this
development as far as we concerned
as presented built upon a national and
local government policies with response
respect to providing access to Green
spaces for all
the replacement for example then close
pass which you've done on a previous
development in kilimash uh just to the
north of the one we're talking about
um creates paths which are undesirable
and won't get in the knowledge silly
wouldn't let these children down and
they don't blame them and we avoid those
parts now because they're just
unpleasant enclosing them is not always
replacing
to use
um the
um well it's still made a point in a
short paragraph that they're into
the access statement it does not refer
to the advantages of existing for Plus
in providing access to wider footpath
networks and extensively used
in other words from those forecasts that
they are destroying them you can get the
old of the
before
but just a couple of points when
considering the derivation of the path
to facilitate a proposed development is
replacement with a tarant coated
roadside Causeway would not be the only
option considered which appears to be
all that we've done in this particular
case and that was referred to in
circular 2 1993 NHD paragraph 7.8 of
circular one stroke of nine
however this weaving the law the council
is granted I was to stubble or dive air
times including forecast to develop
or facilitate the development
the contention the intentious word is
the order for the development to be
carried out it does not say that the
diverted footwork may be destroyed Egypt
for the convenience of that development
and it also points out in words a state
vote should be avoided wherever possible
because although the the layout the
proposed layout does show a line it's
nowhere near the original football line
and also it is no more than a Tarmac
Causeway that you'd have alongside any
Road in a state of this kind
um what they should have done or what we
believe they should have done in the
first case was protect the footpath
which is effectively what most of the
paperwork or most of the laws referred
to in other words you look at the book
but create a corridor
presenting that now it may need it may
mean that it needs diabetes slightly but
not
deal and replacing with the uh because
that is not what we consider to be a
thought pack and people should remember
the importance of these forecasts
including the space in particular
during the cold recovery pandemic when
people
talk to walking doesn't mean that
maintaining and something
um
I do agree the developers should be
encouraged it's an early stage to
incorporate more sympathetic Divine
designs replacement for plus and this is
precisely what part seven of circular
one stroke or nine recommends
I'm not going to do I would ask that you
support the council's rejection of this
proposal aspic is presented and then
there are people can make adjustments
which will make it acceptable to us but
purely from the point of view thank you
thank you
that's everybody that wanted to speak
this morning have a listen
okay well thank you very much for your
contributions and I just wanted to say
that you've represented yourselves
really well and I can see there's been
organization to your comments and you
have stove to not repeat each other with
different
um topics which I really thank you for
and I'm completely understood your
questions
very well so thank you very much
[Music]
there are some points that kind of a
witnesses to cover off and I just wanted
to at some point have a discussion
around this time together
yeah we can do that I think it's
something different maybe
um
because you need make notes comments
when you can comment on them
we'll just pull some witnesses to World
Box points okay
all right
um
I think with that then it's time that we
take a lunch break and um
when we come back we'll start hearing um
evidence from your Council
um
so I'm going to propose an hour for
lunch
um
part two we've got the other pages
thank you very much then I'll see you
all that have to
thank you
foreign
all ready
same thing
okay welcome back everyone apologies for
the delay what can I say I can't do it
in our own way but I thought I could
traffic and
times were I was let down but he was
blowing up so anyway long story short
apologies you know if you're within 15
minutes exactly
well exactly I think the best person
[Music]
before we
run to five months in gym
okay
the thoughts of the councilor I saw the
center of the poor documents because
somebody else
um so I'm going to try and run by
electricity
for both sides and as you go along with
you say everything about a product I'm
interested in the reference and if I am
having trouble that helps our childhood
you know it's only the bigger part
ourselves
um so we'll just see how we get along
thank you thank you inspector thank you
um
what you said earlier about uh to the
point of recently about Google and
competition so I won't try and avoid
that when I'm working through my group
of evidence sums already being put by
our various I think someone will be
given so I'll be working through it in
sections and it's very into different
core documents to work to
uh my evidence covers the issue raised
under the reason for the future that he
was or two other countries
um
[Music]
what kind of proposing to do that I'm
conscious with the parties have seen
this proof of the publicly not
um was was protected seriously deal with
the saving material but you're not
asking
yeah of course you could read it anymore
yeah so come across 1.101
I've been a council of Northeast
Derbyshire assist Council since 2015.
I've been a member of the planning
committee since May 2020 and I was in
the attendance at the meeting 17th of
May of 2012 when everything was taken to
reduce permission development
[Music]
decision and the reasons why the
development would result from any
appropriate elements in the green bill
that is not justified by the very
special circumstances the evidence kind
of the relevant planning policy matters
including nobody structure local plan
policy ss10 and note instead of the show
Greenbelt the development plan on read
as a whole and National planning policy
has accessed in the National Department
policy framework for framework
policies
the relevant lawsuit courses
are set out in the state of Common
Ground the most important policy for the
Greenbelt issue is local plan policy
ss10 relevant policies on the framework
is certain external ground particularly
relevant to the rebuilt issues chapter
13 testing Green Road and paragraphs one
two seven month year 147 to 150.
on the transitional Arrangements there's
some differences between ss10 and
National Greenbelt policy has now set
out in the current framework 2021.
in particular the thing worked 2021
includes material changes in use of land
paragraph 150e and the list of
developments that might not be
appropriate whereas policy ss10 does not
provide per material chain uses I've
acknowledged that we put weight on uh
that uh nftp
2021 is a material consideration uh I
think I'll cover that later on as well
but enough to say on that we put weight
on on both inspects we put weight on
both documents for our first poetry
document is our development plan
which we tend to place more weight on
than we do the national final firmware
other policies will limit to this appeal
or constitute between Conformity with
the current framework 20021 as well as
with the original framework 2012 again
switch to examine
onto 6.2 the allocation size and shade
and it was put forward by our liquor
States and the local process lands of
the West was included on the non-green
belt side so the Northeast was also
added into the allocation the
Consultants so the council undertook the
game belt review 2016-17 identified
besides
allocated as the most appropriate parcel
to us to assess
um
at no point there are all at the stage
suggest any enlargements of the
allocation as a southern boundary and
their representation to the local
publication draft 2018 they provided an
illustrative master plan which showed
development within the site continuous
with the intended allocation which
showed attention funds acceleration
bonds within the extended allocation
side the masterful administrative
representation document is a core
document
4.1.1 C
so the original master plan two points I
wanted to make here if we look at the
coder planning documents
4.1.1 C all of this relates to a plan
that is inside uh what was the kl1 which
was inside the new boundary allocated by
the inspector of the local planet and I
wanted to work look quickly to this
document perspective if we will you'll
be aware of
some code to planning
and make sure the first indicative
master plan and comes in streams in the
industries 296 houses within the
allocation side including the subs and
in their
and if we work through it there's a
statement in here
there's some of the kl1 suitability and
deliverability it states in-depth
drainage work has determined that
suitable and sustainable drainage can be
achieved on the site for both surface
and power water which can be
appropriately integrated without one
dual impacting on the existing
classifieds so that's within kl1
um
what's up with page eight
it's the
first one I'd like to draw your
attention to so at the time now it's
important
not statement there
along the on the next page
and on the next footage
yeah
and this is Page
nine yeah the master plan shows this
using the layout that indicates the
version of 296 dwellings as a result it
is a circuit that the subject side kl1
is easily capable of accommodating this
greater level of development so this is
when we uh when we went from the 2013
into the approximate bigger given of the
local plan uh to the 396 396.
so it's particularly important because
it highlights the importance of a new
rebuild bandwidth that the local final
inspector set in the bottom of the
valley
and as well as that it acknowledges
really like that the developer
themselves technology this is the actual
paragraph to the side the other one and
that this and he says as he said there
on their document it's easily capable of
accommodating this greater level of
development
for all these key to point that out
also seven the main issues
the issue the proposed development of
the Greenbelt Landry's fundamental that
is because the application seek the
mission for a maximum number of 397
dwellings and the intended sustainable
drainage system is an essential
component of the development the
developments of the green ball blank is
found to be inappropriate and not
justified by those special circumstances
than the attenuation funds would need to
be accommodated within the public
allocated side that in turn will likely
reduce the number of dwellings that
could be accommodated the mission could
not be granted for a maximum of 3 out of
seven dwellings in those circumstances
in considering this fundamental mass of
bringing the build development I stuck
to my reasoning around the following
issues
so
page seven of mine
statements whether the development
proposed on the greenbuilt language is
inappropriate development in the green
belt having regards to development
Development Fund policy and National
policy of its person in the framework
the degree of greenville.com
and whether any harm by reason of
inappropriateness and any other harm
would be clearly outweighed by further
considerations social amount to very
special circumstances
at normal
um
well you just said about
um that kind of document what 396 shown
on the master plan with Emily
um
that we just said
it was found in the research was a
completely we would have to reduce the
number of drawings
about uh
how uh the local plan inspector
recognize that band right that natural
ground with us there another sort of
that boundary was accepted by
um by the developer
um we didn't make the compilations onto
what crude oil could have been putting
on to that size at that point uh this
issue is slightly separate from that is
what it is it's talking about a
different points okay but what I can
take away is sets
yes
[Music]
so uh whether it's inappropriate
development that's the first one 8.1 the
applications for outline permission the
plans are proposed for approval are no
more than a red line around the side and
points to access in the assault response
with no Assurance of specific extensive
words the development that would come
forward for the green gold one
acknowledge that by reference to the
chronic's plan for forward as part of
the appeal a planning condition could be
opposed to limit the Greenville
development to sustainable Urban
greenish scene and Rural parks and
tracks even so that was not in itself
into development being appropriate and
within balance
[Music]
such work should be engineering
operations and could also include
building operations
sorry just feel a bit rushed and I want
you to have as much time
[Music]
how those details and how the earth
works as well as those details there
which could be in the green belt how
they affect the openness of being built
later on so I've structured um
bills so I have I have a the reason for
mentioning that from there is uh to say
that it would be engineering operations
and elaborating that there are limited
[Music]
and so 8.4 change of use the use of the
land also falls to be considered the
indicative material submitted with the
application showed the intended use of
the area to be public openstase
incorporating Landscaping you think
about area at some seating
the latest indicative information
submitted as part of the appeal
indicates that the area will simply be
used to accommodate the subs features
switched over the middle of Public
Access
either way the use of the planet has
fully broken space on the service or
just the source is a materials so that's
more about material changing use
involved in how it affects the openness
and the actual
um
what it will actually look like it's to
say it's a change of use that's why it
comes to
um these are the components of the
development that needs to be considered
against local International Arena but
also in order to determine whether the
development is an appropriate
development
and then moved on to
um what I think the Russian without
earlier inspector
um on 8.8 towards the bottom of the term
preservable unless it means having a
mutual effect on openness of the
Greenville is not at all to be
negatively effective
even to the smallest debris the concepts
are open was about spatial and visual
aspects and I shall address both of
those I'll be going through 8.98 from 10
18 11. the illustrative illustrative
materials submitted with the application
shows three engineered contentions
surrounded by banking at one of 1.3
gradients for the three means and
management
margins
but obviously I'd already approve but I
was expecting me to kind of be taken
through oh well in your embarrassing
um you know just asking questions
um I'm having to take a question from uh
um
[Music]
through your um proof
um
yeah that's all right there's no
indication that any material is to be
removed from the side it must therefore
follow the material to form the basis
and then we used to create the banking
and the basis water the big Works can't
do anything just causing you down
[Music]
later on
because it's just at the end of here
uh
and I will refer to it plenty of time to
have to get the documents out
these Works can't do anything other than
alcohol even therefore have a negative
effects upon the openness simply being
built especially so I'm talking about
visuals and spatial aspects of the old
Dimensions any underground tank impacts
and control measures would alcohol you
know if the material excavate them to
accommodate them needs to be
redistrative be distributed on the land
results in yet further negative and kind
of spatial level visually the existing
Baseline is actually gently sloping
field of a classical character
the engineered features in the bankers
would be clearly recognizable as being
for the purpose of the Wisconsin
continuation basis and containing water
and I'm going to belong to that later
and explain that this how it would
actually look aside for them
um on a graphic being provided on a
diagnostic providers I wanted to cover
that first
these will be clearly seen by an
observer from the public network from
within the site itself and from the land
to the cell whatever it can't be seen is
from some of the newer pictures that
have been received recently that have
been caught uh on the on the evidence
rules if you look at it from a book from
a drone or from a fun from above the
things you can't see on the shoe
actually on the ground so what we do is
show a thing greenness when you look at
any uh gradients are very difficult to
see unless you're lucky on the ground
themselves
the plan and Associated photographer and
it's one of my group are examples of
public viewpoints I'm sure
where the attenuation basis would be
seen these added features would affect
the openness negative when compared to
the present situation as it can be
survived and observer of addressing
Fields so then
I would like to
so I believe it the change is do not
preserve the openness of being built the
original plan shows a a true picture of
what the developer does in mind with
extreme mean to maintenance strip around
the outside of the three sustainable
Urban drainage scenes uh head walls
pumpkin Mountain Area all Urban features
that would affect the openness of the
green development now the first
documents I'd like to to go to is the
cross section
3153 which is a plan uh in the
courthouse and it's by a Weber landscape
design
and it's this one it's better
uh what's 3.53
it's very difficulty on paper
when you're on a computer you can zoom
in and you can see the actual staring at
the developments you'll see down the
cybers of scale
thank you
um
today
let's see what's up
I'm trying to demonstrate the
irrespectives
foreign
but it's been
very implied with bundles
um
[Music]
you see along the top of that those are
cross-sectional cross-section and to go
to the left
and that gives an idea of what what this
will actually look like and that's by uh
that's that's being bought by uh by the
developer and it's by as I said earlier
by weather and State Design
if you look the shoes and how one will
be added and I would be taken away you
can see that that there will be creative
2.5 meter high bones
this that has a little fixed so if you
can see the sustainable damage
at the same reason and you can see where
they'll be adding obviously at the
bottom of each one two and a half meters
and you can see it about an existing
ground line
we can also see that they'll be removing
one below that as well so in effect
creating 45 meter what would be the
impact down walls
and if you look at the how it looks at
the name of the ballet when you walk
down the valley you'll see that it's a
it's a pastoral pulling by uh that goes
along the southern border what this
would do the removal of the land below
the walls and the addition of the of the
line of the book it would create
effectively five meter
um
bottom into bonus to the bottom of each
sort of
and you can be seen within that scale
there it's difficult to make some paper
when you look at sometimes you know you
can actually see what that would create
that would sell without any head walls
uh grills or any computer stations that
in itself affects uh the openness of the
green belts
for the visually and spiritually
that makes sense
in addition
um we've got the existing Green Belt
boundary which is in the valley uh where
it currently is the new hedgeville in
the Departments as you can see uh I
think it's on the same go and you can
see what the new headquarter would be
the red line across the top
is in fact the creation of a new
bandwidth by the developers and seeing
if it's not that is the separation
between a built-up area and the
countryside that's that's the
intelligent and for them to take you to
another document and this one is the
design proposal it's on the design and
access statement page 55.
is an idea of what was the intention
from the developer and read this out and
the facts
it's the design and access statements
thank you
no matter it's on it's on the
documents section of the council's
website and 1.2.5
I believe it is wrong
[Music]
that sort of sent to me forgive me I'm
not going to stop an argument which is
at least
anticipate certainly are
because that was 1.1.2.5
foreign
um
what's important about this is for me
when I read this and when we saw when
other members saw this appointment
this was about understanding the
difference between a built environment
and their thoughts
we'd always accepted that the green belt
family was in the bottom of the valley
that was me very clear my planning
officers it was made very clear at the
time of the local plan and the
importance of that was was uh books was
over and over again
and what it says here is something which
which certainly is not that we've been
conflict with that the sack bandwidth is
to find some extreme implants and source
to manage the relationship between the
builds environment and the open products
that we own so for me looking at that
that was the intention all along the
developers of treating this area
both Rings The Green Belt another Dubai
has built this environment
foreign
available to us when there's
applications
is making this application
and then just explain it to me again
probably with this sentence about the
site and being advancing reading in the
family oh no there's no problem with the
significance yeah is that it separates
the builds environment and we overcome
to Beyond so it implies that the built
environment was everything below that
into the valley in the green belt area
that's what we're talking about there
now but that is the built environment
so that is what they consider the
separation now I would always consider
the separation at the bottom of the
valley which was where Green Belt
started
and then when we look at
um and then further to that
um
but what's going to like to make on that
is when we look at potential impact so
that green involves uh I referred to as
a group of evidence from our group the
example in page 42 5.5 that I therefore
consider the potential impact of on the
green not to be very localized to this
area but but on that I do as well
um it's on all this this area of
Greenville just localized area of green
belt is where the input will be so the
impact of those extra problems the taken
with the loan uh beloved below the bones
the building of the performance but
we've got
and then that's a new boundary which is
planted which manages a built area for
the open Countryside
the same there that that the potential
impact will be in that area I believe in
practice of all that area right up to
the uh to the second one you can see at
the top of the hill
and when you look at what it says in 148
of a planning framework we have to play
a substantial weight any harm and the
keeper makes people mean this since that
was it was any harm and all these things
put together the possibility of what
might be put in that sudden area what
sort of generally made up of that all
the body uh the impacts on the openness
uh visually unspeed your way that was
enough and it's still enough now that
that's harm to uh typically about to be
openness
so going back to mine
um
statements
it's also necessary to consider whether
there is any conflict within the
purposes of the green developed the
green belt at any point primary research
two clips services but checking
unrestricted unrestricted scroll and
that was safeguarding the countryside
the local times
8.11
[Music]
foreign
they didn't do that
it just run through the focus and tell
me what it is
I think I think when you look at all
these photos together what you see is
is a value that gently Slips Away uh all
of them should ask from the various
Advantage points you can see the
smoothness of the violin you can see the
openness you can see that it's pastoral
raising one and it's got no uh
attenuation funds and there's nothing
built up on it
there was no Edwards that moved and
creates episodes
the three separate bonds that will be
created including on the first
attenuation upon the first sustained
Urban drainage system they'd also be
putting it at the topic well so there's
none of that to be seen there so what
all these photos show is just a natural
pastoral Valley
probably I think they all show that
together
for example
put me through it
baby I'm here you know it could be good
but it's been reciprocal to talk on
these thoughts
what I would say is uh probably the best
one for me with this one would be that
one with people sincerely but I'm
looking for Aaron uh and and it would be
clear as well when you take that one and
you visit this one when you visit the
site at the end of tomorrow
thank you
so 8.12 is also necessary to consider
whether there is any conflict with the
purposes of it being built the green
belt at this point primarily serves two
purposes but checking and restrictions
in restricted scroll and that's
safeguarding the countryside going from
the local plans to meet the development
needs of the district your plan to
approach accepting that some release of
land of the former Greenbelt is
necessary
relocation or visits the essential
infrastructure for the development would
be accommodates aside
the green belt boundary as revised and
defined in the process recently adopted
local environment have been considered
to do the overtime process
the sub stream is an essential component
for the development that can be
segregated without the residential
development there will be no need for
the service development it represents a
scroll of the Urban Development Endeavor
conflicts conflicts for the green belt
uh third of us
and for the same reason also represents
an urban encroachment instantly notes as
I've said earlier and even when having
regard to the latest indicative material
the sucks development would clearly
recognize what was part of the urban
residential development in acting two
weeks and itself appear on in on natural
engineered form against the background
of the Residential Properties and
headboard so we would we would lose that
that natural learning problem and you'd
see basically it's seen a steps
um you'd see sex groundworks through the
whole valley and it's it's difficult to
tell on the photos because if we don't
have any photos of what it would look
like we can certainly tell from all the
plans
certainly will achieve yeah
I've seen the visualizations but those
visualizations
they didn't look back and console and
not when you compare them with the
actual measurements what you can't see
is
um
you cannot see that at all
thank you
so I would agree that when I work on
those photos approach might be you know
behind some of those photos
I think you've got to remember what
those photos and the area uh views uh
they are all like you know for me
artists artists impressions of what
um they could look like they're not
actual photos of them when they're
finished what is more accurate and I
will go back to it is
ensure the actual ligaments
we are
they were looking at those two children
districts and not far from here they
were always
what I've seen all the episodes and what
sort of have always been made up of so
that seems to become
a common sort of
headphones somehow I wish you've got any
questions on that particularly those
so the two examples of certain model and
what we might look like
so to demonstrate how we're actually
seeing the city would become five one
problem appears as an immigrant feature
with Associated packing and structures
the development therefore conflicts when
we envelope this scene
there are 8.16 videos
of the recently adopted local plans does
not have a material chunk of use and
it's listed developments that may be
appropriate and being involved it's a
closed list was the change of views of
the land from agriculture to service
development is inappropriate with
revolved in the context of the local
purposes
access time is income system with a 2021
framework at this point the framework is
material consideration even if the
framework is a very way in this regard
the news is such that as already
explained it inherently involves changes
to the landforms to its such features
that would affect the openness between
those facial and Visually
the new software will complete with a
green milk purchases paragraph 128 AMC
of the framework even in the context of
being local development is still being
appropriate in the green belt
going back to the uh the material change
of use uh as I think it said at the
beginning uh it's not in our local
information document which it is in the
2021 uh
uh we place more weights uh as a as an
authority on uh the local our local fund
which doesn't do that and we do on the
planning framework 2021. that's not
civilian place anyway it's on the public
places
the conclusion of this issue it might be
that the development of what are the
negative effects on the openness or
station on visual line and it would also
come quick with Green Dot versus ANC and
therefore the development is
inappropriate
after that I go on to degrees.com
has appropriate Development Center
Greenville the developments is harmful
bad definition but Harmony itself is on
the very substantial weight
photographs appendix one show the area
of course for the attenuation problems
photographs demonstrate the opening
Supply and present length at the wide
extent to which you've never seen from
the public viewpoints
earlier thank you from the south of
course Craftsman appendix do show other
substitute elements in the district and
demonstrate the infrastructure Parts at
the organ scriptures that can be
expected in such a development together
with a natural Quantified land form and
student banking
religious funding sections submitted by
the opponents are addictive or like um
subjects into that population neither
scheme was brought forward for approval
in the civil and it remains in the
honest with which final scheme would
actually be but God should therefore be
harvest the appearance of honestly in
the situ and assessing the degree.com
the sort of developments of this area we
will start with clearly display
characteristics of a milligram character
with high volumes as I've mentioned
before we're building up to five units
of bonds with the removal of the
addition of land and three separate
areas eroding openness both special and
visitor and visibility
would clearly be seen by The Observer
from a number of public viewing points
including the ones so the ones uh the
photos that we've looked at earlier
foreign
this part was covered at 8.25 it's
called my master Howlett in the opening
statement but uh I won't cover it again
so I I do find it important so I wanted
to add one more thing to it and
assessing the suitability of the site
the green belt released the local
Finance Factor the particular
consideration to the southern boundary
the need for the history of defensible
boundary and they need to maintain
visual separation between the
development and spring build Which is
less than uh
over kilometer to the sound to prevent
coalescence we often talk about uh
enabling towns that preventing
neighboring town was converging and I
know it's been referred to a few times
uh evolver in the nearest town but in
fact Springfield is the one you actually
see everything else is over the hill
when you're in the valley so the one you
see there is simple at the top of the
church and the buildings
and that is what the the thing there
below is what the uh the local primary
Specter had to say about that the
reinforcements of the Southern history
boundary and example would assist in
mitigating the visual impacts of the
development or drive and will provide a
clear demarcation between the builds up
area and the countryside Beyond and
would create strong independable
Greenbelt paragraph adequate visual
separation will be maintained to the
near-master that's being built for the
prevent coal lessons and this follows
for me to follow us paragraph 143 of the
planning framework
at the time that was spoken about at the
time on Greenbelt boundaries uh defining
Greenback boundaries using physical
features that are readily recognizable
and likely to be a permanent so if
that's the actual value bottom where
they're Burns
is not as it's been suggested by the
developer that it will halfway up
in Instagram that's on the other side to
create a new boundary so all of this
adventure is we've accepted as sort of
the local plan about how important that
Greenbelt uh apparently was at the
bottom the movement of that further up
the hill is in effect the developers
want to move and create a new in my mind
although you're going to sit in writing
they want to create a new green belt
background that's what the look wants to
do to go into it so what I'm trying to
say earlier in my state and it was there
and especially in this code of planning
that the developer considers everything
below that their new band doing what
they consider about they consider that
to be a built-up area and everything
Beyond it to the green belt that's what
we make we're there and why it brought
it in at that point so here uh the
differences with a local plan for
inspector
a recognizable feature that was already
there
foreign
[Music]
that that brings me on to whether
there's very special circumstances
a number of other considerations have
been suggested by the opponents as
weighing in with applications favor in
consideration we run so there is no
reason to doubt that housing development
will come forward on the allocated side
should this proposal be refuse any
benefits deriving from the appeal
development rely on with the difference
of numbers so that's between the 313
and the 397.
for 67 ounces
with those
the development would deliver some
additional dwellings including family
homes beyond the approximate number set
out in the local Parliament for outside
LLC one that would be delivered in any
event however they can present we have
six as you probably know already
inspected 6.94
years how can one Supply on average
extremely sensitive dwellings plan not
being delivered across the districts
over the last eight years
and completions of the last three years
have been 437.65-55
so that's why uh We've brought that part
covered in very little ways
when we look at our objectively assess
media as a council
that was given as 283.
the administration at the time says it's
a 313 which shows that we're trying to
deliver housing and also plan to deliver
on affordable housing as well
so the objects that we assassinated was
282 and 283 so we actually delivered
more than 3 30 next year even without
any on this site at all and the current
projection is 569
so I'm survey 8.29 that's why we put it
very little ways
8.3 the development would deliver some
additional affordable rooms beyond the
number that would have been delivered by
the development within the allocated
side
once the district doesn't need for
affordable alone the Contour would be
small in number and would be the
expensive Greenbelt line so that that
itself carried very little weight as
well and
our objectively assessment what we don't
have for this inspector is a target our
objectively assessment mean is 172
per annum
what we do have is a policy that
requires 20 of houses built to be
affordable
now when this was looked at in the
Strategic housing market assessment of
it was said there that that's not
realistic or Justified that 172 figure
and that the planning system alone
couldn't deliver a lot to deliver on
this obviously we're only building three
little birds out uh a year 20 of that 20
of that is not going to deliver the 172.
arguments
[Music]
pretty according to the main issues I
was set up a long time ago
what we're doing
is chemistry through and adding in stuff
that's not in your crew
because I have nothing to go on for what
you're talking about you're just talking
about me
there are raising means I've never had a
witness
[Music]
please remember it's to help me so as I
said at the start you know if you could
go what helps me understand the
information and not just chat facts at
me that aren't with the stuff that I've
had
that would be helpful I'm not expected
I'm happy to follow advice from uh
um
what I'm trying to do is I've referral
document so I'm going to give them time
to
[Music]
easily found
foreign
is going to
encourage you would be found
uh
yes we're supposed to
you were dealing Under The Heading of
where the very special circumstances
um
and you then gave some additional
statistics about
affordable housing and the denotative
advice you're about
um paragraph 8.30 the consideration of
sun
additional affordable homes
um if one is to which Europe could be a
little weight
um can you explain please
in terms of evaluating weight
Innovations and special service terms
which include our harm
why you concludes with the provision of
some additional affordable homes
is a matter that we carry very different
way and someone will carry little weight
it would carry Little Wings because we
were only looking at the bit but the
only amount that we should be looking at
is the difference between the 397 and
between thirds and 67. so if you're
looking at anything uh 20 of that so if
you're looking at what 30 minutes houses
now when you compare that to the harm uh
foreign
[Music]
and the provision of social
infrastructure
um
how much work you attract attached to
that one uh I myself under punishments
at the time put no weights on that
because uh what was being provided was
only what would be expected anywhere
from the development of this size
the water is your assessment of ways to
be
attributed to economic benefits through
employment opportunity
economic benefits but we should we
should be looking at these figures
because again they're based on the three
man seven houses uh
uh and if they develop the development
of the 330 on the other people's side
instead of the 397 or 396 ask for the
local consultations uh on the same
amount of different side outside the
email these benefits would still be
doing
the only one that carries little way is
the actually economic benefit of the
extra 67 hours but that's at the expense
of the Greenville
and what about economic and Commercial
benefit generally how do you assess the
weight of that if we look at 8.3 weight
should not be given to the clinical
benefit to the house building industrial
benefits and Council in terms of new
broad reports of council tax on that I'd
referred to if I'm uh able to is uh what
it says in the planning practice the
audience on this
um documents paragraph 0-1-1 and he says
when when should a local Finance
consideration to take into account as a
material consideration and it doesn't
uh whether or not a local fan is
considered particular to a particular
decision will depend on whether it came
out or maybe the same development sexual
implantation it would not be appropriate
to make the decision based on the
potential for the development to raise
money for a local authoritative
government
so if we don't accept that as an actual
uh document I'm having to just state
that as an answer and Mr Elwood
and that's from the planning that
planning the practice guidance
I'm gonna imagine it has been special
benefit is the integration previously
within the allocated side
what does what is your assessment of the
way to pay attention to that
well it was little way uh they said that
delivering 40 percent of Green Space
within the development and if you look
at these 17 hectares of the side 1.4
hectares of the darkest green belt
then if you look at our policy
requirements of the local fund
8.58 age
142 with a local plan 30 is our starting
point so I'd say what should we do over
40 when someone is already in Greenbelt
1.4 hectares being well so uh suddenly
there's nothing special there and you're
also factoring the footpaths
um as well and that would also add up to
the quarter percent so sort of for me
that's just as it is so the 40 is
nothing special 30 is not required
anywhere and that's not uh that's only a
starting point
for 30 percent so no so a little way to
beatbox
and then a paragraph 8.35
none of the supported public benefits
see they all went away together well
clearly out where the green belts are
very special circumstances are not
demonstrated
now what I'd like to do is Attack on
harm just in your own words why do you
consider this development
of the accumulation areas to be
inappropriate within the green belt what
is your thinking what it leads you to
that point my thinking is that a certain
Urban green system is by definition it's
relevant and it's within the green pill
it's got many features uh including head
walls from the company sections
all manner different buildings uh all
plants rewards so far look forward to so
they are urban urban systems as pointed
out in the in the code of final document
which I referred to earlier
um
that's that's the actual buildings uh
within uh
but the actual movements of Earth which
affects the uh and the spatial and the
visual aspect
um I've tried to describe that already
but just sum it up it's the
importability to create those shoot
bonds those five meter bonds which would
be 16 foot ponds in uh three of them uh
build them build a covered land uh in
front of the first one that will last
affects sink on the ground
um that is what would affect the
openness both visually and spatially at
the Green Building
again in your own words
what is your view of the effects that
this proposal would have had on the
openness of this could be the world why
do you reach that year
cool but with that you repeat to myself
again I think it's when you're on the
ground and you're walking through that
uh that slow thinking about like that
possible about like as it currently it's
raising one it's quite clear that a
series of steps uh what I would say
would look more like reservoirs a series
would definitely affect the openness on
any elliptical class that would be there
they'd be quite clear on the ground from
any position now the photos we took or
six photos but you could walk in any
direction and you would see this that it
affects the openness it'd be quite clear
from uh on the ground you can see I've
been around the side I've seen the sides
and you can see how it would be
effective and you can see where there
were those those would be when you take
down the actual plan of itself
the only thing you wish to add in
relation to the appointment purposes
but why you think that is
it would not
otherwise
what I would say is
a big advocate of the protection
and I know other members of the planet
Community are that's why we arrived at
this decision and it's not only where we
are now it's about where the country's
gone as well if you look at the and the
most consideration but you've asked me
for a general view so it's not a
consideration that I accept
there's a commitment amongst many many
politicians I've been out by our central
government made to further Greening of
the green belt and that's what's being
said
um uh and the examination of the of the
new one paper also not forcing councils
to to review it so my opinion is that
it's our policy as it stands the
planning framework and our local plan is
still not as strong as it shouldn't be
in protecting a window and I think
that's recognized by a central
government that's why because they're
pushing that direction
so so you know I I do believe that we
should be protecting this they say your
green belt and I think this this would
certainly be a
you know every city every significant
harm of doing that as it described
um and for me the appeal should uh
therefore fail
both sections
they're funny balance and confusing yeah
you give quickly summarize the last
three paragraphs 9.1 to nine points uh
there are no considerations
between favor of the branches Bank
relationship with the development
[Music]
the framework
the framework is not a consideration
went against the development plan and
the proposals forever
so the decision should be made in
accordance with our development plan our
local plan and the interview
s
okay
um
that brings out policy it's barely put
me out if we want to work
so
you're telling me this is a complete
development in green emails
have you got a copy of the national
Planner yeah
so it's inappropriate for that in your
view because
it doesn't fit within that list that
and what will it says certain other
point of view are also not an
appropriate uh try to preserve its
openness so I'm arguing that it does not
preserve from the start of the uh
that's just very very beginning so which
which under 150 with it potentially that
of the world
it could put their engineering
operations yeah so we've said there's
something
um
foreign
if we looked at this it would pick
something
yeah that's right okay
that's where we're potentially sitting
on 150 BM now they really have to
consider with an engineering operational
material change of use
things think about so
you're saying to me I think I don't know
if it works anymore
and just remind me of the only one
we can have it at this time
all right welcome happiness as I said
earlier they split between uh visually
yeah yeah
okay
um and visual right
especially that's really like this is
that's all about uh about the uh the
amounts of it that are being released
from one place over there what's the
what's the addition possibly at
different times a year uh and different
weather environments and the addition of
Awards as well so so the addition of
water the removal of uh of one place
another the creation of the bones the
creation possible I hope the knowledge
was the new band right uh further it
works there so all that movements at the
minute as opposed to the status
and it flows down
um
so that is very very when you see it
it's a very very open area
so there is an openness to the green
belt there that stretches all the way up
to Springfield
and any movement down there and it's
when you look at it it's quite
substantial movements about the works
and the creation processing of three uh
three Subs effectively three damage
because of that within itself
[Music]
um
so especially if you're telling me it's
the question of uh funds the digging
still around putting it in a parallel
there yeah
and when that Hollow fills with water
spaceship that's special that's what
your opportunities mean yes I mean
anything else special
that might be affecting opening
yeah
other structure
I was looking at those from the visual
aspect right it's included in a in a
spatial aspect except so I was looking
at those motivational aspects okay so
nothing else space you then
okay so you've been physically what's
taking up our opening this thing visual
life is the same thing we have to move
into the world so it's at least
integration of those High buttons thank
you again so just say that yeah okay
yeah uh and then
um any head walls any compensations any
any other engineering I think of uh
there's a list that I put in my uh yeah
foreign
and looking and see they're both two
sides of the I mean one is protecting
the the countryside from the city so
Safeguard in that kind of design and
that's below that uh on one side of that
Greenbelt that I'm going to see and on
the other side checking the unrestricted
score of those barriers and as we've
heard from Witnesses so much is a large
building area a little even larger was
development so this development wants to
go down to the uh
you know so it's sort of a green belt
it's that green belt down that would
check that uh that only secrets for
techniques they just experienced
something
how these
animation bases
um
in your mind
represents a school and location
that's because of the art Urban designs
in themselves
and
everything everything else
um and also going back to that through
the document they are accepted by a
minute it's a bit Urban designs in
themselves sorts so
I think the drugs to travel all living
which describes uh sort of as a built-up
area and that new bandwidth further of
the Hill Instagram belt has been the
separation between Countryside and the
belt of area so that is still I mean
it's a built-up area the Urban Design
and we are part of this world themselves
oh and I do accept that it's not the
same with the Harris absolutely
so so uh I would never argue with that
but it's still Urban and designed by
what we are
probably done with that that's how you
get to inappropriate apparently
um
carries a substantial weight I mean
[Music]
so that's wonderful right
um substantial way it should be given to
any class you think that
um but it's good practice to quantify
the degree of any harm to openness and
practices
so I'm interested in making you work um
and
it just start over and I don't mind
going through each again but I've tried
to cover that in my uh
in my group of elements from 8.21
um
it was a substantial way
in 8.21.
we're using paragraph from paragraph 48
in the framework uh yeah when
considering when considering any
planning applications
substantial weight is given to any harm
that being known absorbed but the fact
that it is hard it's uh anyone a
substantial weight so
your views
anyone
you don't expect to find a degree in
problem so you know all sorts of
different types of cards depending on
without driving safe
small sexual offense so you could have a
development of a thousand hours
would you give both
I mean they both carry a substantial
weight but would you
give any would you guys contemplate
would you be apart
know that we've given
ESS
of that and I would say that it's uh if
you're choosing that out and yes you'd
be right to say I would uh I wouldn't
give the suds uh
which is a real Harris's University
absolutely
so you can give me a degree of um to the
sense
um notion that we will give it
substantial weight I'd say considerable
okay considerable
um and I know it's all in the choice of
words but in my own words I would say
considerable
um that's because uh and I go back to
that longitudinal assessment that
diagram with if you've got 15 spot
bottoms a series of those
I do understand the answer and why
um and why you see the harm but what's
your scale then considerable right at
the top is it religion
uh well I've always understand if you're
looking for a choice of words we can
choose disastrous
yeah okay and what about if we had
something like
okay
let's go with your words but you're
saying considerable then this was the
middle of your scale of um
but you would say it's towards the
middle yes okay
I'd be happy
um I'll be happy to you give me your own
description of what what new thoughts or
other stored
those degrees were and I've been happy
to describe where it went a man fall
there but if you're asking me for my
description I'd be saying you know my
own description
but to understand where can civil rights
and your scariest things
um can we just go back to the master
plan that was on ring around
but this is considered when it
eventually began which I think was
0.1.16
4.1.1 C Eastern master plan
um
inspects always looking at
when to tell me what would this site
would be elevated from housing
thank you
the uh
I just got a master plan
I've got that codifying yeah
where we see it the third place so I
think it's going out of six houses with
Subs Within
the profanity
foreign
[Music]
School
boundary that the inspector is talking
about along
well we've actually got here then is
that is that a plan at the side
these aren't my documents these
documents are working
the computer and these documents are
more about
um the layouts of ar1 is this still kind
of an inspector is talking about and she
talked about a different School boundary
it's it's not the uh this was a plan but
that was the line that was the thing
that boundary
is
this is a I know she was talking about
that boundary along the bottom and this
is the plan that was uh this was a
master plan it was made of that boundary
and this is one that was available it
was at the point
okay
sorry sorry
this was our disrepresentation for the
local Planet this one
so London was available to
what was the other one it was this one
that was available
it was this one yeah
with the applications like this I
believe
master plan
yeah
there's something made of the fact that
she said
thank you
yeah now I learned that she's always
yeah
do you want the outline what this one
so what's the statistical that I'm doing
it's along that line there actually
okay
all right
um
last question all right which I'm sure
you'll read the story of relief
um
we've weighed into we'll be taking into
consideration other harms deletion
I think I think it's mainly what is what
I've put in my group of evidence
covered all the harms
[Music]
so the green belt yes but will that any
other hands
well what I come to speak on is about
part of the winning goal
right and that and that's it's
reasonable reviews
I think we all we already uh we've
already decided in the council but we
wouldn't be Dependable no the right
reasons for example I think we found
this in substantially partner to
approach assets
such as well
um normally of having witness would
deal with the main issues and then do
enable planning balance but that's not
what you're here today
[Music]
um
yeah it's the way today's
Times yes we do yeah the only thing is
that we talked to split your professor
Foundation well I think about this case
what do you what does everybody think
and I'll leave happiness
[Music]
we would
finish up tomorrow
let's see
um
foreign foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um first of all I'm just a little bit
surprised to see you in the witness here
um there was no indication about the
case management conferences
an indication of that in the discussions
over the statements
um
Council does have
an external professional running officer
witness which is a teammate yes
um
did you understand if she's prepared to
give you
uh and I I think I think we discussed it
in passing but I always intended to be
able to volunteer anywhere no indication
of that previously
in that case standard
well
as a as a timing witness of making crime
or is this something that you're looking
for no
important
do you have any running qualifications
will be how many time qualifications no
no uh just experience and uh internal
training and I understand what's going
on with some LGA
did you write the proof
I got a good idea
and uh so I can ask the detailed
questions about it
we're done
can I just quiz you a little bit about
your role in the decision making I mean
this will be an assorted to be in mind
we can go to the core documents on this
if we need something I suspect we won't
first of all when your decision was made
by the Planning Commission again it's
not as a recommendation in May last year
when it is refused
it was you that raised the motion to go
against the officer recommendation it
was
and in November
November the 22nd committee when the
council resolved not to defend any of
the refusalem
you weren't practically
women
and the minute of that meeting is pretty
clear that the council said having taken
legal advice
and in order to save costs
in terms of particularly an expectation
that there might be a cost applications
against them the reason for all we would
rule that's right that's great
but then what seemed to happen next I
think is that
um only a short time attitude is a
special committee
because
somebody asked for that decision to be
received was that you
thought most uh a few counselors at the
time I think it was six that were
involved
um
I was wanting back one of that suits
afterwards first position that was made
um it's difficult to say but when uh
there was 12 monthly councils and what
they said were they felt uncomfortable
with the decision that had been made
uh I wasn't sort of first meeting the
legal advice was uh a roundability
in the viability of challenging levels
[Music]
another answer
can only
um understand this and that's extra
needs of the December 13th
you actually wrote emotionally supported
all in women's
now you said to all of those but uh I'd
say yes yes well well we can this is to
save time but cleopane if you want to
have a look at it it's in CD 1.3.6
and you will find that um
that's the page
when I'm seven
where you brought any motion to even say
actually you know we'll have all of
those reasons for teams
and that meeting
um I thought there was still relevant
much of the work beginning absolutely so
left to you
we will deciding them all the thing is
it's uh these things aren't left to me I
don't know I'll just I'm trying to
understand your position I'll explain to
you so you would understand it uh my
position was I thought those seven were
still all valid green zones but I didn't
expect it but the committee as a whole
because whenever Visions were made
that's been made with a group counselors
uh the family members of the whole felt
that only one
and that's why we decided not to the
clinically decided and so did I because
sometimes when you're an elected member
let me finish on this see if I've been
elected one but it's not just your room
you've got the opinions of either
resonance forward or the membersa and I
really disagreeing with that I'm used to
govern my own readers at least I'm used
to dropping uh things with other
people's
um
considerations on board and that's what
I did in this space so that's why I
myself now I'm not fighting uh the other
states absolutely
um
I was one of the six people so one of
them was to ask the police
and sometimes you are actually Minister
there's a good person being brought
forward
the decision
to bring in all of the reasons
um
and that was my position at this and it
is now
good now can you have a look at the
council's statements of canvassing we'll
find out someone of the Callback
communities
I've asked her um
I think it was nearer
[Music]
thank you
what should have almost time
so this was the county Source statement
of careless
which was submitted in January
did you have 100 names
I haven't even done this together now
I
suspective thing uh
so if you turn to page three again 3.3
those reference to uh material that was
ultimately submitted on the third of
February if the inspector agrees to
submission in further Evidence the
council would like an opportunity to
consider them in the comments upon it
also see comments and advice comments
consultees as a code
and we know that that was explained to
be in advance that materials provides
more or less sort of material for the
foreign
have you taken that opportunity to seek
comments and advice from consult teams
or others
and what happened I mean preparing mine
statement what I have done is
from others as to the effect of that
material
I remember myself
I don't know if anybody else has ever
Council but I haven't
to me and why not
well
see it seems to me that you persuaded
the committee to reinstate reason to in
relationship
the old American Experience the cancer
did the council get a chance to have a
look
in order to see whether it made me this
no I think what we're going to do we
looked at what was provided by our area
to the council where there were any
other Consultants no
he didn't take you back to members to
say look I would have got all this
material in now does it make a
difference to the position
because the reason was refusal was about
a clean black and International
it was yeah and
um on that
um
it was uh
if we go back to the middle of it around
that point yesterday
it wasn't about lack of information
on information that we had that's
important so just sort of unclear then
more information is provided and you've
not gone back to the council and you've
not gone back to any of the concert
scene
you've not sorts only advice from anyone
you just said find defending this reason
for the teams also um
that's what happened but we also went
somewhere else legal advice on Mr Howard
at that point
really
yeah
[Music]
from
now we'll come to the actual reasons
refusal I don't think you need that
documents in the documents anymore
that's talking about the case
so
it's common ground because it's stated
in these statements as common ground
that reasons for the views will have to
be clear with size page
and indeed that is that is a requirement
of of Regulation
decision
two one five on the statements common
ground it says it's in terms of 35 is
now becomes a Planning Development
management order
that's one question about the students
have common ground I'm asking you a
question about whether or not you agree
with me the reasons for the news that
would have to be
a precise and so on
so let's have a look at reasons reviews
on number two
and if you've got the status of Common
Ground that's two little places I need
to see
because it's on the same page
science extends beyond the settlement
development
located
for you has been submitted therefore
is completed that without information to
the country it was first prisoner of
evidence in terms of the actual reason
are no sufficient and countless new
information details
and therefore it is assumed not to
preserve openness into conflict with
purposes because those pieces of
information the cancer claim work would
say
what was it
was that reason perhamster
[Music]
details therefore so it's because of
those lack of details it is concluded
without the information to the country
it wouldn't fail to visit over the
Western confidential purposes
and so it was the lack of details that
made you as a council when this refusal
notice was drawn up concludes if we
don't have the information we will
presume
it is going to be not preservable unless
and conflicting with purposes I think
it's about to say about
um we are an alternator as a planning to
multi information on uh this is a lot of
information is available when it's
presented to uh
and there was no attempt on the 13th of
December or the 22nd of November to
recast the terms of those things
I think
and there was no attempt to add anything
to it no
and those details have now been provided
and you haven't been back to them to ask
them the question is that sufficient
so your evidence is yours without actual
Mandate of the council
okay
but what you're now saying if I
understand it is that what it is it's
not a lack of detail so much as this is
in fact something that you say will not
preserve progress and real matter of
things
further
uh you know that the committee said
however this is real talk between to set
at the time that the openness of the
green belt would be effective and we did
discuss
um how some were born we discussed the
openness to bring about we discussed
however
the committee is just that so it wasn't
about lack of detail plan because they
were able to form a good deal now
selling and what's written here and
about a lot of details and therefore
it's presumed that it will be harmful
is is revising
no we're
the beats that we had at the time we
were allowed to make the decision that's
what we did all right
let's have a look at some issues in
relation to policy within that reason
for refusal
um this is a sort of an underarm Bowl
but that reason that the boxing talks
about time being 10 as well as ss10 and
1910 results and longer starter here I
think yeah
um but let me just understand this
you're not relying in making your case
on any other local brand policy at all
we're meeting on ss10 as well
and just to be clear
you're not relying upon SS one or two or
nine or less than four or lc1
well when we look at ss1 that's an
overarching policy and
foreign
conditions
[Music]
um
you say in your proof
that
political instruments of that same
concerns
but you also say you're going to say 2.4
you also go on to say it and excuse me
that this team
in the greenhouse
could include several things and you you
give us a whole list of things you talk
about buildings
to talk about structures we talk about
headwinds
we've spoken about how do you always the
sound familiar you've spoken about
chains
we've spoken about all sorts of
structures and when our civil nature yes
you're not trying to tell the army that
it isn't possible to impose a condition
to prevent those things should be in in
the course of the site which is really
well
with the simplest of conditions today
it could be but it wasn't just that and
he was like I said before it wasn't just
the uh the assembled equipment
it was about that that's that is an
issue
I would say what I'd like is a very
clear Point yes or no it is clearly
possible between owners of our mission
to quickly from the Green Belt all of
those things that are interested much
like I said in 8.20
could be involved
and we know don't do this it's in the
National framework that has conditions
are to be used in order to make
development accessible but could
otherwise not be
um
we know also that the oppg then goes
down
I don't know that it's paragraph 21 a
double zero one
make developments acceptable avoid
reasons to refuse or composed conditions
like able to be vagina
foreign
[Music]
um
so five one we'll see if you wanted
immigrants number 16 zero and four nine
the rest of this is just the notes was
created
program 16.
foreign
points
and it's one two three four down
[Music]
-048
foreign
[Music]
things that you asked for us
quite a burden on using get for Grant
yeah because if you reject conditions
they couldn't complete the same people
things then that could be unreasonable
behavior and it could be reliables
I realized the burden and that's if
you're just talking about those
accelerated equipment
um
it doesn't uh
it doesn't also the point about the rest
but we always have a clear view of what
some would be uh the size of the of the
Enlightenment we created so he always
had a place
foreign
yeah
so this is all the news
so there are a couple of decisions that
I'd just like to have a look at with you
if I occursion and the first is cv6
and the second is in the same bundle
over the six ones between the Queensland
and New York
6106 first of all then 603
thank you
just before we dive into that
um in the long term discussion that
we've just had about conditions
right these and the answer that we
gained just before
is it now your case because it certainly
seems to be
you're not concerned about kind of
similarious structures because you want
to celebrating the admission
I'm so concerned about whether where
those state laws would be because all
the plans
when it comes to so what you're saying
is you do you not to accept the
conditioning from you know is to make
sure that they are nice
and so that aspect of your case on your
assertive buildings and that other than
similarly matters
we'll come to the ground Lincoln I'm
going okay I'm just Carling that exactly
but all other matters you don't accept
completion so they're very power markets
those and yeah those are some just sort
of unsung
which hopefully we have 616
and we see it's a decision from respect
to Clark
let's pull the wharfs down
you see it's an outline it's
uninformation was granted it's the 70
dwellings all of us
and we turned something because
paragraph seven
part of the site lies within the green
band but it's accepted
the use of that particular site for
Israelis Basin would not be an
appropriately
there is no suggestions such limitations
that are secured by a condition
the council's development on policies on
the use of land in the group that would
applying any events
um so any reserve Master's application
we didn't either
so let's just impact that from this
debate
first of all the condition I was talking
about would go to provide an even
greater control when Paul Clark was
content we could see that it can just be
that one that Reserve masses
right the second of all that is a sub
Basin in the green clouds
um
never mind
um concluding with them without any
question whatsoever
or seated by the council he respond to
any other point
confined
but that was not inappropriate
not an inappropriate thing in the room
were you aware of about this evening
before you
this is the person I've ever heard it
was
now let's just have a look at another
decision which I said in Return
Solutions
a little recent
when
we came out 14th of December
2022 were you aware of this one at all
so this is in two parts because here we
have a secretary of state decision which
the decision went from the front of the
main sectors
and so the secretary state
inspections wise
uh
we see here we go to the end of the
decision that's the grants tournament
for a site that um
there was entire anything about that
I mean the suds and we learned that
David princess in paragraph one was the
inspector
we're also learning that paragraph that
it's an outline planning application
it was for nearly a thousand dwellings
pieces
and then if we go to paragraph 16
where we've got many issues and we have
to bear in mind that here the inspector
or the inspection centers
in Greenbelt that was across the
internal Society really where the houses
were
um it's paragraph 16 there's no dispute
between the parties proposal would
amounts of an apprently development
that's what the house
the Secretary of State agrees with
proposed country path would be a change
of use for recreation and the necessary
engineering operations despite
disabilities actually not ir1 because it
would not let themselves amount to an
appropriate development to the reasons
exam
so so keep a finger in there but we'll
we'll move forward to the inspections of
the board which follows on in 131
and I don't know whether your company of
one or three one is highlighted violence
against us can't go down the high lines
starts and proposed Country Park
is Page 31 of The Institute
the text the phonics changes as you go
along
Recreation proposed of sustainable
drainage infrastructure would be created
within the country belong with amount to
engineering operations I mean I'm going
to find out the 150 in the framework
these elements The Proposal would not
have themselves allowed to inappropriate
development because they wouldn't
preserve the openness we would not
contact with the services
could it
well this is the first time I've read
this so
so this is a development for nearly a
thousand kilometers
and this is so just dealing with the
water attenuation for nearly a thousands
of clearly videos
that's what I'm trying to do
but I've got no knowledge of this uh
whether there's any what whether this
one affects the openness now uh I can't
sometimes I don't know the case well
let's just have a look at this time
you've seen this drawings of tendencies
the material that was before the
inspector on the Secretary of State
have you got this pregnancy
[Music]
and you know should Bluestein
I think he's going to I think I think
that's it is number six
and we wrote Mr Robinson's evidence
because you mentioned to know some talks
about the massive leader so I'm
surprised that it was that it's the
first time we've seen the decision
foreign
um
the patient level of detail
and I'm not very
um and you get some sort of feel of the
scale of those basins
when you look at the scale of the
rodents of structure
about that
was was nowhere there's no cross-section
there but I haven't seen but it's
difficult
to do what they've been practicing but
this isn't something we won't really
inspection with all the Central States
has gone oh I need a bit more
information
I mean it needs some normal information
it's just a this is an easy one
that's the way it's presented in
the importance of the century stating
you're not dealt with something
agreement before
these inspectors have
proceed to get a lot of airtime in my
decision it seems to be amazing
good question yeah what was the question
this is an easy decision there's no
there's no leaktime analysis there are
large sort of spaces particularly
families we know what they are
cyclopsis
when it came to this particular
application I'm not talking about
hunting I'm not talking about what I'm
talking about that's what they're
killing much
um your offices that were
not troubled buyers at all either
return to the office of reports we'll
have a look at that and see hopefully
this will be wonderful you want
foreign
it runs over the page as far as 7.7
.3
by sentence in this case
nobody buildings but those of the green
about areas of the site
so important form is a bit of appraising
of the Australian word 150
over the page 7.5
application tutorial outline
number of attenuation Bonds in the green
vowels saying what it says Last Detail
layout and design of the site that we
determined it was a master stage the
applicants has indicated they'll accept
and issue there's only nine little
development is attenuating problems says
associated with infrastructure that
we've dealt with now to the most cases
in the Green Valley area
and 7.7 is considered this can't be out
covered by a suitably working
conditional wrong and conditioning
acquiring details of engineering and
other operations approaching upon us
foreign
that might be the case might not because
I I want to attend an absolute Beverly
meeting
um
it's not just the case of the retirement
officers isn't it because I'm sort of
dividing you know this is a case-size
the policy officers of the council some
exactly the same thing as well anyway
show me
welcome back to the loss of America
um let me ask you another question
before I come back soon
Amy can you explain to me
um
whether there is anything in terms of
national policy
you know all Secretary of State
decisions or inspects of deciduous or
other decisions at all
that you or the council relied upon in
order to depart from that information
what will you use reporting what did you
destroyed that it was SSN
and uh
discussed the violence in order to make
a judgment in in territory it was
Australian she knew
which is something the place where
you're punishing that you ability it was
something for the first time
let me just send change check recycling
with my procedure
it's no part of the council's cases that
you can't have any time in principle
for subsequencies
no
so it's it's a matter of judgment rather
than anything else there's nothing
inclusive you know
um
and and just sitting along the same
point that we just extend what's on the
process to systems and you're not saying
that sudden times are always
[Music]
foreign
um if if new and the rest of the council
commencement order
foreign
[Music]
problem
we didn't appreciate that the council
has several ways about building and
asking for more information we could
just ask
it yeah Discerning that
but actually there's affordable process
as well we actually request in a manner
that means that it would not provide
within the application is is
foreign
[Music]
settings
and
yeah I still have more small notes about
the policy response that wants you to
have a look at that
um
at the end
for instance
approach to New Zealand's flexibility
optimizing and then the last sentence
furthermore the attenuation basis which
are located
just in those the days of that it's 20th
of January 2012.
and
I'm not throwing them for the timeline
on this side but that was before the
whole batch of information about the
relationship promise is submitted to
read the application to support an
application
on the 25th of March 2022 Mr Robinson's
appendix songs
so the points I made was a fairly short
one we know the final analysis case
happens
information the policy officers
China land before application of the
team so that was so much
and yet the reason for the refusal is
still based around
not enough information
development
and I just started going to release I
think it's the background between the
allocation of the local fact and there
was potential fossils and it's it's
probably more than a 10 minute point and
but I mean you all hands pressed online
um
I'll do either I just didn't want to run
two phones
right in the end of its own so and
you're available
[Music]
to talk about before we all great for
today
you alluded to yourself but I'm sure
counselor for Australian status yeah
is
okay